Spider-Man homecoming Stars the third
live-action Spider-Man since 2002 and
that barely even begins to scratch the
surface of how many Spider-Man have
appeared on screen over the years
Sam how do they stack up here's a look
at the major versions of Spider-Man from
TV and movies and the actors who played
them ranked from worst to best
70s live action Spider-Man it is an
actor Nicholas Hammond's fault that
nobody remembers the short-lived Amazing
Spider-Man TV show from the late 1970s
he just didn't have that much to work
with there were no super villains no
Supporting Cast from the comics except
Jay Jonah Jameson and a single
appearance by Aunt May and Hammond never
looked talked or moved like anything
other than a random guy you'd run into
at Comic-Con
[Music]
Spider-Man Unlimited Spider-Man
Unlimited was basically an effort to
extend the 90s animated series past its
sell by date by sending Spider-Man to an
alternate Earth voice actor Reno Romano
just did his best impression of
Christopher Daniel Barnes who preceded
him in the role
not only am I carting around my worst
nightmare it's leaking the costume
derived from the Spider-Man 2099 Comics
is memorable but it probably would have
worked even better if they just made a
Spider-Man 2099 cartoon
60s animated Spider-Man considering
Spider-Man it only existed for four
years when this show started relatively
few viewers had a clear idea of just
what Spider-Man should be like Paul
soles as Spider-Man sounds the way 1960s
cartoon viewers expected a superhero to
sound which means he sounds exactly like
Superman I once swore never to turn my
back on anyone and I'm not starting now
this Spider-Man is best remembered today
as the star of many animated gifs and
memes and of course for its Awesome
theme song
1981 animated Spider-Man the 1981
Spider-Man animated series wasn't bad by
any means the animation was solid for
the time and it brought in a lot of
spider villains from the comics who'd
never gotten TV time before the weirdest
thing about this show is that it was
immediately overshadowed by another
Spider-Man cartoon Spider-Man and His
Amazing Friends which premiered the same
day the 2 Series also used the same
character designs which kind of made
this series feel like a run of
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends in
which he has no friends and talks a
little funny thanks to the vocal talents
of Ted Schwartz oh
[Music]
Neddy the electric company Spider-Man's
first live-action appearance
interestingly enough was on the electric
company a 1970s educational series that
ran on PBS this Spider-Man played by
Danny Seagram didn't talk but his simple
Adventures were the perfect vehicle for
teaching kids basic language and math
skills but the highlight of the show The
narration which was provided by a
pre-famed Morgan Freeman and he's found
it
a rubber glove sandwich
Spider-Man the new animated series two
things are distracting about 2003's
Spider-Man the new animated series the
first is the combo 2D and 3D animation
the second is that every time Spider-Man
talks he can't help but hear Neil
Patrick Harris this is so not spandex
not that Harris is a bad choice for
Spider-Man but come on isn't he more
suited for villainy Japanese Spider-Man
the 1978 Japanese Spider-Man live-action
TV series has a cult following in the
U.S even though it's never been
officially released there in this
version Spider-Man is a motorcycle
driver who gets his spider powers from a
super bracelet from the planet spider
the show is a lot of fun and the actors
do a great job but it just feels wrong
to rank them any higher when they're not
playing the same Spider-Man as everybody
else
[Music]
what's up
two thousand Spider-Man movies in the
early days of 21st Century superhero
movies Toby Maguire got the job done he
got in great physical shape for
Spider-Man but he still had the softness
to play nerdy Peter Parker
punch me I bleed
while he never quite seemed like a kid
in the way an origin story Spider-Man
should he was still young enough to be
believable as a teenager making him a
solid version of the webslinger Ultimate
Spider-Man
Disney's first animated Spider-Man
series after it purchased Marvel some of
the production decisions for Ultimate
Spider-Man didn't sit well with longtime
fans especially the decision to hire
Drake Bell of Drake and Josh to voice
the Title Character you don't know how
that feels I do actually
someone important was taken from me too
but if you look past the bad Buzz
Bella's actually a pretty great animated
Spider-Man and he also comes through in
the darker moments that require a more
emotional Peter Parker Amazing
Spider-Man the biggest problem with
Andrew Garfield is Peter Parker is that
he was already too old for the part when
he starred in The Amazing Spider-Man he
never seems like an awkward teen and yet
the rebooted franchise offered another
origin story set in high school
still his slim build looked good in the
suit and his comic timing made him a
natural fit for the rhythms of the
characters constant Wise Cracks
90s animated Spider-Man for a lot of
Millennials Christopher Daniel Barnes
was the definitive voice of Spider-Man
throughout their childhood while this
Spider-Man has aged a little awkwardly
it was the first TV version of the
character to really draw on the comic
story lines in the nuanced way
introducing Concepts like the Venom Suit
The Secret Wars crossover and even
Daredevil this series skipped the origin
and began with Peter Parker already in
college within that context Barnes is
perfect in the park balancing the jokes
and emotional baggage that are both so
Central to Spider-Man
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends for
those a little older Dan gilvizan was
the Saturday morning Spider-Man of
choice he voiced the central hero on
Spider-Man and his amazing friends from
1981 until 1986. his Spider-Man had the
lightness that earlier versions of the
character have been missing while still
seeming more grounded than the goofy
reisman
oh no
oh yes this cartoon seems pretty silly
by today's standards but this was the
first time Spider-Man really seemed like
Spider-Man and that's worth something
The Spectacular Spider-Man Spectacular
Spider-Man was basically the perfect
Spider-Man cartoon and one that ended
too soon
it ran for two seasons in 2008 and 2009
and was being considered for a third
when Disney bought Marvel and reacquired
the television rise to Spider-Man
leaving this Sony produced series unable
to continue voice actor Josh Keaton
played the youthful Spider-Man with the
earnestness of a kid trying to do his
best and it really worked it's just a
shame there couldn't be more of it uh
Yoo-hoo excuse me can I come in this way
or do I have to break my own window
Spiderman
MCU Spider-Man as the third live-action
Spidey in under a decade Tom Holland May
finally be the perfect choice he comes
across like a young teenager with a
surprising amount of power and his
youthfulness stands out perfectly in
contrast with all the adult Heroes
running around in the MCU are you
an app basically Spider-Man homecoming
presents him as a nerdy high school
student who might be in way over his
head and that's exactly what Spider-Man
should be especially within the context
of a larger avenger-centric setting
if you're even slightly a fan of
Spider-Man you're in for a treat with
Sony's new animated movie there's enough
hidden away inside the film to keep
surprising viewers on their second third
or even fourth watches here are just a
few of the Easter eggs you might have
missed and Spider-Man into the
spider-verse
while spider versus ultimately An Origin
story for Miles Morales the spotlight
does get shared with other spider people
the first hero audiences are introduced
to is the Peter Parker of miles's
universe the movie starts off with this
Peter's narration catching viewers up on
the broad Strokes of the Spider-Man
story during Peter's recounting of his
exploits as a superhero the movie
revisits several classic set pieces from
the Sam Raimi spider movies including
Spider-Man's heroic train rescue the
time Dr Octopus threw a car through a
window and the much derided sequence of
an evil Peter Parker strutting around in
Spider-Man 3 shooting everyone some
finger guns
oh God
everyone knows that Marvel loves those
classic Stanley cameos but some of the
shout outs to other important artists
from the company's history can often be
harder to notice spider-verse provides a
bit of a call out for two other figures
who were crucial to Spider-Man's
development when miles is on the train
shortly after discovering his powers he
pulls out his phone and Scrolls through
the contacts passing by a conspicuous
entry for B Bendis a reference to Brian
Michael Bendis who co-created miles with
artist Sarah pikelli in 2011. later in a
similar moment with Jefferson Jeff
Scrolls by an entry for Steve ditko who
co-created the original Spider-Man with
Stan Lee in 1962.
though miles is Brooklyn Born and Raised
he also seems to be a fan of the
chicago-based MC Chance the Rapper with
a poster for his mixtape coloring book
appearing in miles's room amusingly the
distinctive baseball cap chance wears on
the real life cover with a number three
on it indicating that the mixtape is his
third release has been changed in Miles
alternate universe to the number four
the implication is that the chance of
this universe is slightly more prolific
than the version we know maybe miles's
Universe just put a lot more emphasis on
the Lil B collaboration
we all know that Spider-Man is more than
just a character he's a lucrative
multimedia property and into the
spider-verse has fun with that fact part
of Peter Parker's intro to the movie
focuses on the extensive library of
spider merch that's been created over
the course of his crime fighting career
with one of the most amusing products
being the Spider-Man Christmas album but
this isn't a joke that was made for the
movie it's actually a joke from real
life the album in the movie is a
reference to a real Spider-Man album
that was released in 1975. a rock opera
from the label Life song records called
Spider-Man Rock reflections of a hero it
sounds like Jefferson Airplane singing
jaunty songs about how no one's got a
crush on Peter Parker it's kind of
awesome and in some alternate universe
it's probably a chart-topping hit
there have been so many Spider-Man suit
designs over the years at this point
that you could spend days putting
together a list of your favorites into
the spider-verse showcases a number of
alternate costumes inside of Aunt May's
secret spider layer several of the suits
visible in the background are cooled
from spidey's long comic book history
and also show up in the Spider-Man PS4
game particularly the advanced suit with
the white logo that was made just for
the game you can also spot suits
reminiscent of the black and green
stealth big time suit the electro-proof
suit the black suit from Secret war and
even a look similar to the black dust
suit and the most humorous suit which
features a clunky looking superhero cape
originally appeared in Marvel Comics
what if number 19 published in 1980. I
think this is a cape at separate points
in the movie both Peter Parker and Miles
Morales take a break from their crime
fighting on the head of a pantheres
gargoyle jutting off the side of some
New York City architecture Peter has
some coffee and reads the newspaper
while miles strikes oppose highly
reminiscent of another superhero
t'challa himself the Black Panther the
movie features imagery that originally
appeared on a poster for the Black
Panther movie released during the 2017
San Diego Comic-Con in that image
t'challa can be seen in his full black
panther suit looking out over the
horizon under soft lighting as he flexes
his glutes for the camera do you think
miles's Dimension has its own Marvel
Cinematic Universe
miles's police officer father Jefferson
Davis presents himself as a guy who
likes Law and Order so what better way
to indicate his allegiances than with
the reference to the TV show Law and
Order in the beginning of the movie
miles gets a ride to the vision sporting
school on his first day from Jefferson
and his police car the license plate for
Jeff's Car is rfd960 which is actually a
reference to the detective's vehicles in
the original Law and Order series which
always featured the same license plate
through the show's entire run
just like in real life there's a lot
going on in spider vs Times Square one
billboard in the neighborhood is an
advertisement for a Broadway show called
hi hello which is actually reference to
some other work from a member of the
movie's cast the advertisement is a take
on the real-life show oh hello on
Broadway which starred comedians Nick
Kroll and John Mulaney Mulaney of course
is a part of the spider-verse movie as
the voice actor of Peter Porker the
spectacular spider-ham
I'm right here shortly after all of the
spider people converge they meet for a
pep talk inside of miles's dorm room
which he shares with a roommate when the
roommate returns unexpectedly they all
dart up to the ceiling shuffling around
the corners to avoid being seen while
the roommate reads from a comic book you
may notice that the comic book refers to
a story called imagine that there was
more than one Spider-Man imagine that
indeed while Marvel Comics never put out
an imagine that line of comics the
company does have a series called what
if this speculative line of comics
published since 1977 usually focuses on
weird one-off stories allowing writers
and readers to explore wild hypothetical
scenarios such as what if Spider-Man had
joined the Fantastic Four of course
something just like that actually
happened many years later so clearly the
idea was pretty good
the post-credits scene for spider-verse
thrillingly introduces one of the best
and coolest spider people Miguel O'Hara
AKA Spider-Man 2099 at first it seems as
though the Stinger will be setting up a
futuristic spider verse sequel but that
notion quickly sails out the window when
Miguel travels to the goofy alternate
universe of Earth 67. in Marvel Comics
Canon this world is the home of the
cornball 1967 Spider-Man cartoon and the
sequence quickly becomes a big joke when
Miguel arrives he immediately encounters
the 67 Spider-Man after which they
proceed to recreate the Spider-Man
pointing at Spider-Man meme for what
feels like a full minute and then the
movie ends it's arguably the weirdest
funniest post-credits scene in a genre
that is full of them and the perfect way
to send off the Silly Love Letter of a
movie
is no way home the most emotionally
devastating Spider-Man film to date no
doubt about it keep watching for a
rundown of the film's most emotional
moments Major Spoilers ahead many fan
theories about Spider-Man no way home
proved to be accurate especially that
Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield would
appear from the time they arrived
Maguire and Garfield serve as mentors to
Tom Holland's Peter Parker teaching him
that they've also experienced immense
losses fortunately they'll be by its
side when it comes to fighting off the
remaining villains and curing them of
their various ailments as expected they
saved the day but sadly it's at a high
cost Holland Spider-Man asks Doctor
Strange played by Benedict Cumberbatch
to make the universe forget about him
that means everyone he's ever known will
forget about his existence so before
strange performs the spell Peter Parker
goes to say goodbye to those who helped
him starting with the other Spider-Man
it's a heart-wrenching moment because
it's at this point we know it's quite
possibly the last time we'll see the
three live-action Spider-Man shows
screen there's always a chance they
could return in a future installment but
that's far from a sure thing at this
point for now it's just goodbye after
months of speculation that all three of
them would share the screen together it
actually happened and just as quickly as
it was confirmed when away saying
goodbye to the other Spider-Man is tough
for audiences to watch but what comes
next is far more devastating after all
the mcu's Peter Parker has only known
these other Heroes for a few hours
meanwhile he's been friends with Ned for
years and dated MJ for a brief but still
meaningful period of time but as a
result of Dr Strange's spell whose two
best friends will ultimately forget
about him it's far more emotional than
what Peter originally wanted to happen
when he asked strange for help at the
beginning of the film Peter merely asks
the sorcerer to make everyone forget
that he's Spider-Man he still could have
been with MJ but she wouldn't have known
about his secret identity with this new
spell which is necessary to prevent
forces from other dimensions from
entering their world she has to forget
about Peter entirely Peter hugs Ned
goodbye and kisses MJ knowing this is
the last time they'll know about one
another he has to say goodbye to the
best thing that happened to him in
recent memory and he struggles to part
with her near the end of Spider-Man no
way home MJ insists that Peter find her
after Doctor Strange performs his spell
Peter then goes to the coffee shop where
she works complete with a prepared
speech about his feelings for her
admittedly it's a strange way to go
about telling someone something
Monumental Peter's plan basically hinges
on telling MJ who doesn't recognize him
at this point that he loves her we're
betting that no amount of reminiscing
would allow her to recall who Peter
Parker is either however it's how this
scene unfolds that's genuinely
gut-wrenching to witness Peter is
prepared to tell MJ who he is but he
notices a wound on her forehead he
doesn't say it but we as the audience
can tell what he's thinking he knows
that if he tells MJ he's Spider-Man and
continues dating her he'll only put her
in more danger after all she almost died
when she fell off the side of the new
Statue of Liberty Peter recognizes the
best saying for MJ is not to know who he
is so he takes his coffee and walks away
it's a scene that embodies everything
about the Mythos of Spider-Man he
frequently has to cast aside what he
wants for himself and do what is good
for the rest of the world
there's a significant moment more than
halfway through Spider-Man no way home
Tom Holland's Peter loses someone close
to him and as a result he's hesitant to
carry on his mission of carrying the
villains before sending them back to the
realities he talks about a person he
loved who lost their life as a result of
his actions and both McGuire and
Garfield are there to tell him that he's
not alone I can't save everyone
Holland's character tries to tell them
they don't know what he's going through
but little does he know they have
experienced all of the same things
Garfield's Spider-Man tells the story of
how he failed to catch Gwen Stacy during
a climactic battle as seen at the end of
The Amazing Spider-Man 2. he then
describes how his failure caused him to
act more violently to the point that he
barely recognized himself Maguire's
Peter Parker then shares the story of
his Uncle Ben's murder he recalls how he
went down a path of Revenge tracking
down the man responsible and killing him
to be Peter Parker is to have gone
through unimaginable pain these
heartbreaking stories give Holland
Spider-Man the courage necessary to
continue with his plan to save the
villains rather than outright killing
them the MCU spy Spider-Man films made
the decision not to show the death of
Uncle Ben on screen it's alluded to at
various points leaving fans to believe
that in doing so the franchise would
simply skip over Ben's hole with great
power comes great responsibility speech
right before his dramatic death this
isn't necessarily the case thanks to one
pivotal ant May scene when the villains
decide to Ambush Tom Hall and Spider-Man
they really put him through the ringer
the fight concludes with a Green Goblin
throwing one of his signature pumpkin
bombs at Peter and Aunt May Peter goes
to make sure his aunt is all right when
he tells her he wants to abandon the
plan Aunt May reminds him that with
great power there must also come great
responsibility it's heartbreaking
because the audience can guess what's
going to happen next Aunt May's injuries
are too severe and she dies in Peter's
arms he can't stay there to properly
grieve because the police are on his
tail believing he's the one responsible
for all of the damage he runs into the
knights with his biggest supporter no
longer there
in the early 1990s director James
Cameron convinced Carroll Cove pictures
which produced movies such as Terminator
2 Total Recall and Rambo to option the
film rights to Spider-Man but Cameron's
production was ultimately Tangled at an
inescapable web why couldn't one of
Hollywood's most powerful directors get
this film made oh no
no
[Music]
too edgy Cameron's plans for Spider-Man
have become a Hollywood Legend according
to Rebecca Keegan's book The futurist
the life and films of James Cameron
Spidey Creator Stan Lee absolutely loved
camera's treatment ultimately many of
Cameron's own ideas like spidey's
organic web shooters and Uncle Ben's
carjacking death made it into the Sam
Raimi directed Spider-Man movie from
2002 but for every one of Cameron's good
ideas there were at least three that
were not Cameron called for Peter to
curse like a sailor which would have
resulted in an R rating and then there
was a scene where Peter peeped in Mary
Jane's window as she dressed and one
where Spidey and MJ get intimate on the
Brooklyn Bridge while Peter describes
the creepy way spiders mate uh what
[Music]
low budget Cameron would have likely
made Spider-Man right after Terminator 2
which had a 100 million dollar budget
according to Janet wasco's how Hollywood
Works Carol Coe only committed to a 50
million dollar budget a huge step
backwards for him and if the reported
budgets of his next two films 100
million from True Lies and a
record-setting 200 million for Titanic
tell us anything that spotty's balance
sheep wasn't going to fly bad casting
rumor has it that Cameron wanted to cast
Arnold Schwarzenegger as Dr Octopus
Schwarzenegger even pincted his
involvement in an interview with Empire
only going so far as to badly say that
the studio went in another Direction
there are yet more rumors and reports of
Cameron's dream cast of the film and one
of them is a pretty strange Choice
Edward Furlong whose Big Break came as
John Connor and Cameron's Terminator 2
was reportedly the director's pick for
Peter Parker and Leonardo DiCaprio was
to play Harry Osborne of course Leo
wouldn't play second fiddle to just
anyone Johnny Depp for sure Eddie
Furlong not a chance the report also
pegs Drew Barrymore as Gwen Stacy and
Jay Jonah James would have been played
by our Lee Ermey the drill sergeant in
Full Metal Jacket
that would have been perfect but it
wouldn't have been enough to make up for
tanking the principal cast
litigation while the script casting and
budget issues all could have become
later stumbling blocks but ultimately
squashed Cameron Spider-Man were in
legal issues Cameron told collider that
when Carol Co collapsed a few years
after they acquired the rights to
Spider-Man he already had Titanic in his
sights moreover he no longer wanted to
pursue Spider-Man because of all the
competing interests for the rights amid
Carroll Coast bankruptcy and Marvels
apparently a number of former writers
and producers all claimed to have had a
hand in developing the project and they
all came calling Marvel's own 1996
bankruptcy process scattered multiple
holding deals to the win according to
how Hollywood Works after Marvel
recovered from bankruptcy it basically
paid off everyone who was trying to sue
for the rights to Spider-Man which freed
them up to sell the rights to Sony
meanwhile Cameron turned one of the
greatest human tragedies of all time
into a billion dollar smash so he did
just fine I'm the king of the world
world
all of the Spider-Man films tend to
feature the same elements over and over
again while a lot of it's worked well
for the character for about 60 years you
could go to the theater and play Spidey
Bingo pretty easily here are things that
we see in every single Spider-Man movie
let's start with a gimme here if you
have a nephew or niece and you find out
they've been bitten by a radioactive
spider and developed fantastic abilities
like sticking to walls or super strength
pack your bags and get out of town as
fast as you can otherwise you're headed
for disaster admittedly the death of his
uncle is the most important part of
Spider-Man's origin story but still
watching an old man get shot starts to
lose its impact when you've seen it over
and over which is especially problematic
in the Sam Raimi Spider-Man trilogy we
get Uncle Ben's murder happening in the
first film a flashback and tons of
references to it in Spider-Man 2 and a
completely different version of it that
involves the Sad Sack movie version of
the Sandman making up a huge chunk of
the plot of Spider-Man 3. remember Ben
Parker
the old man you shot down in Cold Blood
it should probably be noted that this
particular brand of tragedy isn't
limited to Ben and Spider-Man into the
spider-verse Miles Morales watches as
his own uncle is killed in front of him
as for the MCU those movies have managed
to avoid even a mention of the late Ben
Parker so far with only a couple of
oblique references to Peter's defining
tragedy far from home however is going
to take place in the aftermath of Tony
Stark's death he's not Peter's Uncle by
relation but he's definitely served as a
father figure and if there was ever
someone in Peter's life who fit the
weird Uncle archetype it's that guy hey
mate how you doing what are you wearing
something skimpy I hope
one of the most interesting choices in
Spider-Man's design is that he's one of
the few American superheroes whose
costume leaves him completely covered
from head to toe his mask doesn't even
have a mouth just a pair of big opaque
eyes this works pretty well in comics
but in movies where actors use their
faces to you know act it presents a bit
of a problem that's probably why the
Spider-Man we see in the movie theater
seems like he'll do whatever he can to
get out of that mask regardless of how
it impacts his secret identity again the
raymie trilogy is the biggest offender
in this regard not only does Peter's
mask get shredded by villains with a
frequency that makes you wonder just how
many spares he has laying around he'll
occasionally just whip the whole thing
off sure it's a lot easier to tell a
character struggling when you can see
their face but eventually people are
going to wonder why that kid who's
always taking pictures of Spider-Man
never seems to catch him without his
mask on we won't tell nobody
along the same lines homecoming features
a recreation of the famous comic book
scene where Spidey fights his way out
from underneath tons of rubble in the
comic The Mask stays on but on the big
screen Tom Holland Spidey takes his mask
off to get some fresh air and keeps it
off so that we can see empowering
through his super heroic feat of
strength Andrew Garfield's Peter Parker
shows off his face an Amazing Spider-Man
to help calm down a boy who's in danger
it even extends to animated acting in
into the spider-verse where Spidey loses
his mask just before he's killed by the
Kingpin and Peter B spends most of the
movie unmasked and in sweatpants
there are very few things that superhero
movies love as much as a good
old-fashioned dose of crucifixion
imagery you might recall the scene in
Man of Steel for instance where Our
Hero's ghostly spacefather tells the sun
he sent to Earth that he can save
everyone prompting Superman to stick his
arms out and start hovering in a pose
that's pretty familiar to anyone who's
ever been inside a church while that's
the least subtle example of this Trope
Spider-Man's movies have even more of it
in action that's probably to be expected
in a story of great power and great
responsibility but once you start
noticing it you'll find it happens a lot
Spidey stopping the train in Spider-Man
2 is the most obvious instance but when
Peter tries to hold the ferry together
in homecoming we get the same thing in a
pretty similar shot Spider-Man 3 even
has an entire sequence that takes place
in a church finally adding parasitic
alien symbiotes to Classic biblical
imagery into the spider-verse actually
manages to parody the movie's
crucifixation twice in the first two
minutes including a shot showing a
spidey bathed in rays of sunlight that
gave just a tiny bit of a Halo one of
the most compelling parts of
Spider-Man's story is the impact that
his super heroic career has on his soap
opera of a love life it's the source of
endless drama and it usually gets pretty
complicated the same goes for the movies
every single Spider-Man film has a love
story right there at the core of its
plot with all the twists and turns that
you'd expect in the Remy films it was
Peter's on-again off-again relationship
with Mary Jane Watson which started out
complicated and only gets more Tangled
as the films continue especially when
Gwen Stacy shows up in Spider-Man 3. an
Amazing Spider-Man Gwen was free of a
love triangle but that relationship had
no shortage of speed bumps in the first
film Gwen's dad wanted to arrest
Spider-Man for his vigilante activity I
think he stands for what you stand for
sir protecting innocent people from bad
guys I stand for Law and Order son
that's what I stand for okay I wear a
badge this guy wears a mask like and in
the second a series of spats wound up
leading to Gwen's tragic death
homecoming through a different kind of
wrench into the gears with Peter's crush
on classmate Liz not only did he have to
deal with constantly letting his friends
down due to his arachnid activities he
also had to contend with the reveal that
her dad was a super villain who figured
out Peter was Spider-Man literally 10
minutes after meeting him
Spider-Man into the spider-verse
complicates matters further thanks to
its Dimension hopping plot we've got a
Peter Parker who's dealing with a
divorce from Mary Jane with whom he's
clearly still in love and a different
Mary Jane who's dealing with the death
of her world's Peter Parker and those
are just the minor characters the main
romantic tension in that movie is
between two people from different
realities that's a tough one there is
long-distance relationships and then
there's my girlfriend you don't know her
she lives on Earth 65.
Spider-Man's roster of enemies is packed
with characters who are actually pretty
sympathetic unlike say murderous clowns
that only want to watch the world burn
super villains like the lizard and the
Sandman have motivations that we can
relate to and come with a heaping
helping of pathos that the movies are
more than willing to bring to the screen
the Green Goblin in Spider-Man is the
outlier here since it's pretty hard to
be sympathetic when you're pumpkin
bombing an old lady's bedroom while
she's saying her bedtime prayers
then again even he has a scene where
Norman Osborne is being tormented by his
own alternate personality Doc Ock and
Spider-Man 2 is shown to be a pretty
decent guy before he's driven to
multi-armed criminal insanity and an
Amazing Spider-Man Kurt Connors the
lizard just wants to regrow his lost arm
the vulture in homecoming is maybe the
least sympathetic guy of the bunch I'll
kill you
and everybody you love Royal has talked
about sticking up for the little guy
Adrian tombs drives a jaguar and owns a
massive house in New York City bought
and paid for with the profits from his
high-tech arms dealing business but
still his stated motivation of wanting
to take care of his family is hard to
argue with and if nothing else he keeps
Peter's identity a secret rather than
seeking Revenge into the spider-verse
goes the furthest with this not only do
we see the prowler as a regular guy
hanging out with his favorite nephew but
even the Kingpin has a shred of sympathy
in there yes he kills Spider-Man with
his bare hands and had a plan that might
have destroyed all of reality but it all
comes from his desire to see his wife
and son again their methods are bad but
their desires are very human and pretty
far from world domination
in his first appearance Spider-Man
didn't start out with his familiar
spider suit instead his first outing
after getting his powers was in a pretty
terrible homemade Ensemble and that's an
idea that the movies have kept around
there's always a bad costume first in
Spider-Man it was a recreation of a
scene from the original comic where he
fought a pro wrestler while wearing his
sweatsuit and ski mask tricked out with
a stenciled spider on the chest an
Amazing Spider-Man it was a red mask
with dark wraparound Shades the MCU
actually flipped the script a little by
starting Peter off at least as far as
the audience is concerned in a Comics
accurate version of his famous red and
blue suit provided by Tony Stark it's
only at the end of homecoming that he
goes back to his homemade hoodie into
the spider-verse however Takes the Cake
on this particular Trope with bad
costumes all over the place not only
does Peter spend most of the movie
rocking sweatpants and mismatched shoes
but Miles Morales doesn't get his
costume until the very end before that
most of his spidery adventures take
place while he's wearing a cheap
Spider-Man Halloween costume purchased
of course from smiling Stan Lee no
refunds incidentally these are all just
bad costumes if you're looking for the
evil costumes well that's a different
guy
outstanding
Spider-Man's life is pretty much defined
by tragedy it's the core of his
character the hard luck hero aspect that
makes him so easy to relate to but if
the movies go back to that well all the
time it gets both boring and a little
too depressing as much as we like
watching him get knocked down it's
always better to see him get back up
again that's why the movies always show
us something to remind us that being
Spider-Man is actually kind of awesome
and more than a little fun after
everything
I still love being Spider-Man I mean who
wouldn't
spider-verse gives us all kinds of
moments like this from Spider-Man
cutting an album of Christmas carols to
the extended comedy of Miles
accidentally getting his hands stuck to
Gwen Stacy's hair throw in some karate
kid style web swinging lessons and it
does a great job of showing us that
having superpowers is actually pretty
cool the Remy movies do it too leaning
into zany comedy with Peter zipping
around the city on his weblines to
deliver pizza he even looks like he's
having fun with that dance number even
if no one else is Amazing Spider-Man 2
takes that to the next level with Spidey
getting to his graduation through a
series of wild rides and slapstick
crime-fighting hijinks it's homecoming
that does this best though with the
Montage of Peter's after school
activities as the friendly neighborhood
superhero not only is he excited to get
out there and start doing good he gets a
churro from a nice lady that he eats
while hanging out on a fire escape and
even does a backflip when he's asked to
by members of the public that's what
sets Spider-Man apart from the other
superheroes he's the guy who will stop
and argue with you about who makes the
best sandwich yeah the best sandwich
Queens subhaven is pretty good oh
there's too much bread I like bread
one line in the Hawkeye series
referenced a big events in Spider-Man no
way home and even if you've been keeping
up you still might have missed it here
are the other big Easter Eggs only real
fans noticed in Spider-Man no way home
Spider-Man no way home goes to some dark
places but there's a lot of joy and
humor in the movie's more creative
moments especially all the parts where
universes Collide Jamie Foxx's revamped
version of Electro is arguably the
funniest character in the whole film
even though they're from different
universes his Max Dillon strikes up an
amusing relationship with Thomas Hayden
Church's Sandman during the movie they
both realized their superpowers were
given to them via some kind of horrible
accident Clint Marco fell into a
particle accelerator while Dylan fell
into a pool of genetically engineered
electric eels as elektro says to Sandman
looking back on their Mutual mishaps you
gotta be careful where you fall
another one of the movie's fun
referential lines comes from Star High
School reporter Betty Brandt
completely aware of Peter Parker's duel
life she remarks at one point go get em
tiger or should I say spider
Tigers it's been a long dramatic
somewhat confusing road the line is fun
for a couple of reasons first of all it
makes sense on its own because Peter's
school mascot at the midtown school
happens to be the tigers that itself
would seem to be a bit of a reference to
a classic catchphrase of Mary Jane
Watson okay I'm tiger
of course Kirsten dunst's delivery of
the line was itself paying homage to
Mary Jane Watson in the comics who fond
of the pet named tiger since her first
appearance in the 1960s Mary Jane
herself may never quite appear in the
MCU Spider-Man movies Betty paying
homage to MJ Classics fave pet name
another intriguing one-liner reference
in no way home occurs when Peter is
brought into an interrogation-like
situation following his exposure as
Spider-Man while trying to defend
himself Peter Parker says that Nick Fury
could vouch for his heroic actions but
he's promptly told that Nick Fury has
been off planet for the last year what
in case you've not been keeping up
between the events of the last Avengers
films and Spider-Man far from home it
was established that Nick Fury has been
off on a most mysterious Adventure
somewhere in outer space when Nick Fury
returned from his disappearance during
the blip he attended Tony Stark's
funeral and then apparently arranged to
have the Scrolls Talos and Sauron
impersonate him and Maria hill we don't
know the exact reason why yet but the
arrangement seems to be in place that he
or possibly he and Maria both can take a
long work trip slash vacation in outer
space the scenario was teased explicitly
in a post-credits scene for Spider-Man
far from home showing Nick Fury looking
surprisingly comfortable during his
mission aboard a skrull spaceship
whatever he's doing out there his own
personal Star Trek seems likely to be
wrapping up soon with the timing to
coincide with the upcoming secret
Invasion series on Disney plus which
will reportedly shine a light on the
shape-shifting Scrolls mysterious
activities on planet Earth
one no way home Easter egg isn't even in
the movie itself so you definitely
shouldn't feel bad if you missed this
one
hi in the fifth episode of the Disney
plus series Hawkeye the New Black Widow
Yelena Bulova talks about being in New
York City for the first time she makes a
reference to wanting to visit various
landmarks including the new and improved
Statue of Liberty I want to see uh the
Empire State Building
the new and improved Statue of Liberty
and
the Rockefeller Center in a Hawkeye
Series this comment doesn't quite make
sense but when you see no way home it
all starts to fit together in the movie
we see that the Statue of Liberty is
under construction to replace its torch
with Captain America's shield and the
scene plays host to the movie's
climactic final battle since small
indications like Christmas music and
decorations seem to pinpoint no way home
is taking place in December and the
Hawkeye series explicitly takes place
near Christmas it seems like Hawkeye and
no way home are set fairly close to each
other in the series continuity
arguably the most entertaining scenes in
no way home have nothing to do with our
wrecking Highway confrontations or
Statue of Liberty smackdowns the real
fun happens during a handful of Quiet
Moments When Spidey and his two new
Spider-Man Pals played by Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire compare notes
on their three somewhat similar but
often distinct universes both Maguire's
Peter and Hollins Peter have an MJ
Garfield does not Holland and McGuire
have both fought aliens Garfield has not
but perhaps the most enjoyable bit of
shop talk is the Trio's discussion of
Toby Maguire's organic web shooters
which you might recall became a hugely
controversial issue in those simpler
days back in 2002 when Hollywood saw
superhero movies as more of a box office
Gamble
at the time director Sam Raimi
essentially said it made more sense that
someone bitten by a radioactive spider
taking on the qualities of a spider
would be able to shoot webs biologically
it seemed to make more sense he reasoned
than having Peter coincidentally possess
the scientific and Engineering Acumen to
invent web shooters these days audiences
are used to Peter Parker's web shooters
being built by somebody as in the comics
that makes it all the more entertaining
to hear the questions the other two
Spider-Man have for Maguire's Peter
Parker does he ever get the web
equivalent of writer's block do any
other parts of his body shoot web fluid
those wings carbon fiber is this stuff
coming out of you the three Spiderman in
no way home essentially represent Peter
Parker at various stages in his life
Holland is the naive Earnest youngster
Garfield the jaded heartbroken loner and
McGuire still apparently in a
relationship with Mary Jane has learned
how to balance it all and find some
semblance of happiness one of the most
memorable powerful moments from the
Spider-Man franchise came in 2014's The
Amazing Spider-Man 2 when an imperiled
Gwen Stacy fell from a high distance as
Peter grappled with a villain
desperately trying to save her Peter
shot a web but it was too late this
tragic death of Gwen Stacy of course
mirrored one of the most famous moments
in comic book history another memorable
moment in the franchise came in 2002's
Spider-Man when Willem defoes Norman
Osborne attempted to use the blades of
his Green Goblin glider to impale
Maguire's Peter Parker from behind
leaping out of the way at the last
moment Spidey lived to see another day
but Osborne was killed in no way home
Maguire is the Spider-Man who steps in
when Holland's Peter Parker gives into
his rage and is about to similarly kill
Osborne with the Goblin glider Andrew
Garfield's Spider-Man meanwhile has a
powerful moment humming to Holland's Aid
when MJ falls from the Statue of Liberty
this time in a powerful moment rather
than watching an Another Love of Peter
Parker's life die the Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man is able to successfully shoot
a web and save her
when Peter's secret identity gets outed
he and his friends are detained early in
the film by damage control a men in
blacklike government agency that seems
adjacent to Shield they appear to be
primarily interested in issues of
concealment and public relations while
this isn't the first time MCU fans have
seen damage control it's possibly the
most substantial mentions of damage
control go all the way back to the
original Iron Man film and they're
referenced on an episode of Agents of
shield shield will take all the wounded
men into custody and damage control
cleanup
in Spider-Man homecoming the agency
fired Adrian tombs aka the vulture from
engaging in his private scrap operation
instead they took over the cleanup of
sensitive materials in NYC and set
events in motion that would lead to much
of that film's plot in 2015 Marvel
announced that the damage control
organization was going to be the subject
of a comedy on ABC obviously the series
never made it to air and it seems quite
likely that many of those ideas have
begun seeping their way into MCU
storylines like what we see in no way
home but none of this is all that new
for fans of Marvel Comics who have been
encountering damage control since 1988
and saw the organization play a
substantial role in the civil war comics
multiple Spider-Man are swell but you
can be forgiven if a cameo that excites
you most in no way home comes at the
beginning of the film when Peter finds
himself in illegal hot water happy and
Aunt May sit him down with none other
than Matt Murdoch played once again by
Marvel fan favorite Charlie Cox that's
it let the devil out Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige recently told
Cinema Blend if you were to see
Daredevil in upcoming things Charlie Cox
yes would be the actor playing Daredevil
where we see that how we see that when
we see that remains to be seen well it
didn't take long this is exciting
because it's the first substantial
crossover we've seen between the MCU and
the Netflix live action TV shows and
since Daredevil ended its run on Netflix
many fans had started to think it would
never happen seeing Cox in no way home
at the same time that Vincent D'Onofrio
made his first appearance as Kingpin in
the fifth episode of Hawkeye makes for a
thrilling time in MCU phase four taken
together it's confirmation that feige
and Marvel Studios mean business when it
comes to Bringing at least some of the
Netflix characters back into the MCU
so the devil is back
there aren't many superhero roles that
match up the Spider-Man in terms of
cultural impact countless hopefuls of
auditions for the path of Peter Parker
in his various incarnations over the
years including some of the biggest and
most unexpected names in Hollywood we'll
never know what might have happened if
one of these guys had been cast to
Spidey but it's fun to wonder he has a
look at some actors who are almost cast
as Spider-Man Heath Ledger Heath Ledger
will forever be remembered for his
game-changing performance as the Joker
in Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
but the lay actor could have wound up on
a good guy's side if Sony had gotten its
way in the wake of his death Legend's
former agent Steve Alexander revealed
that his client was the Studio's number
one choice when it came to Casting the
lead in some Remy Spiderman the actor
was ultimately put off by how little he
knew about the character telling his
agent he would have been taking somebody
else's dream away if he took the path
without fully appreciating Spider-Man's
history Jake Gyllenhaal of course the
part of raimi's Peter Parker ultimately
went to Tobey Maguire and the rest of
Spidey history Maguire was propelled to
A-list stardom after the first film
stormed to the top of the box office in
2003 but he almost never made it to the
second movie after sustaining a back
injury while filming Sea Biscuit in 2003
Jake Gyllenhaal was drafted to take his
place though he was dropped when Maguire
made a miraculous recovery just in time
for shooting it isn't the only time
Gillen Hall has narrowly missed out on
playing an iconic superhero he was also
close to playing Christopher Nolan's
Batman only to be beaten to the role by
Christian Bale
James Franco it's not uncommon for an
actor to come away from an audition
having failed to get the part that they
went for only to be contacted and
offered another role in the picture this
was the case with James Franco who read
for the lead role in some Remy Spiderman
but was ultimately beaten to the prize
by Toby Maguire
look at little Goblin junior
I'm gonna cry
Franco confessed that he was
disappointed when the director called
him to let him know the partha gun to
Maguire though he softened the blow when
he instead offered the Freaks and Geek
Star the path of Harry Osborne son of
the Green Goblin and Peter Parker's best
friend Franco agreed under the casting
call for Harry was immediately withdrawn
Daniel Radcliffe when Tom Holland was
announced as the newest Spider-Man Harry
Potter star Daniel Radcliffe was among
those who offered public congratulations
to Holland but his compliments may have
come through gritted teeth Radcliffe
went on to reveal that he wanted the
part himself while also conceding that
it was now Out Of Reach I would have
made a good Spider-Man but they're both
assailed on that one I'm not sure if I'd
sign up for something that was another
seven or eight films or 10 years but a
shorter franchise yeah he did get to at
least live out his dream by cosplaying a
Spider-Man for Comic-Con though so
that's nice you know you don't go to
Comic-Con without going down on the
floor and seeing it all
um and so the way I came up with doing
that was Spider-Man
Leonardo DiCaprio just because we didn't
get a big budget Spider-Man until 2002
that doesn't mean there wasn't earlier
attempts one of the big what-ifs and
superhero movies is the James Cameron
version of Spider-Man which the
acclaimed director abandoned in favor of
Titanic Among the Stars Cameron
considered for the lead role was none
other than Leonardo DiCaprio who read
the screenplay and met with Cameron to
discuss the role DiCaprio never did get
to Don those tighty spideys but Cameron
gave him a pretty good consolation prize
the lead role in Titanic
and that's not even the earliest try to
cinematic Spidey Tom Cruise after
several failed attempts to negotiate a
deal to get Spider-Man swinging onto the
big screen in the late 70s and 80s
Marvel finally signed on a dotted line
with Canon films a production company
known for churning out low budget action
films Texas Chainsaw Massacre director
Toby Hooper was signed up to director
script that actually saw Peter Parker
mutate into an anthropomorphic tarantula
Tom Cruise was offered the part to
opposite Bob Hoskins as iconic Spidey
villain Dr Octopus but unsurprisingly
Cruz decided to pass on the bizarre
project but wait it gets even weirder
Michael Jackson in 2009 marveled
legendary Stan Lee told bewildered
audiences at San Diego Comic-Con that
Michael Jackson had once invited him to
his Neverland Ranch to ask about
personally producing a Spider-Man movie
with the late King of Pop intending to
take on the starring role himself but
Marvel said no Jackson came up with a
new plan buy Marvel out so he could play
the role when I told him I didn't think
the company would sell he then wanted to
buy marbles so then I'll buy marble I
don't know what happened I mean
obviously he didn't buy Marvel but he
wanted to very much yikes
[Music]
when Teenage nerd Peter Parker is bitten
by a radioactive spider he gains a weird
selection of arachnid powers and spends
the rest of his days balancing vigilante
crime fighting against leading a normal
life except it's never really been that
simple for our friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man and his history has so many
twists and turns that it's not easy to
keep track of his tangled web a true
original in 1954 Halloween costume
manufacturer Ben Cooper Inc began
selling a Spider-Man outfit the
kid-sized Duds were little more than a
yellow Ensemble covered with drawings of
webs and the word Spider-Man written
across the forehead giving the overall
impression of well a poorly dressed
idiot who'd recently escaped from a
basement or something years later
Marvel's Spider-Man made his debut in
1962's Amazing Fantasy number 15. the
final issue of a doomed Anthology series
while Cooper's earlier Spider-Man may
seem like a huge coincidence the case is
Complicated by rumors that Jack Kirby
the original artist for Spider-Man
before Steve ditko took over was working
for Ben Cooper at the time Comics site
news arama explored the case and got a
terse reply from ditko and Silence from
Marvel which definitely sets our spider
sense as tingling spider Origins Redux
artist Jack Kirby had his hands in the
creation of just about every major Comic
character you've ever heard of while the
first appearance of Spider-Man was
written by Stan Lee and drawn by Steve
ditko Lee originally had Kirby draw the
first five pages of spidey's Debut the
pages didn't hit the mark and were
scrapped for the final version Lee's
original plot and Kirby's costume
designs were changed and Kirby
ultimately only drew the cover of
Amazing Fantasy number 15. unfortunately
this didn't stop Kirby's heirs from
trying to claim payment for Marvel's use
of Spider-Man in 2009. even Lee Kirby's
Everlasting partner in Mighty Marvel
creativity denied the Kirby family's
claim according to deadline the suit was
settled on undisclosed terms in 2014
which is even more suspicious than
Norman Osborne's crazy cornrows 20
Ingram streets over the course of 1989's
Amazing Spider-Man numbers 316 and 317
readers were shown two halves of a
change of address form filled out by
Peter Parker and only curious readers
who assembled them saw that The Parkers
were now living at 20 Ingram Street in
Forest Hills New York whether or not
this was an Easter egg planted by writer
David michelini or artist Todd McFarland
is unknown but as of 1974 there really
was a family named Parker at that
address who soon began receiving mail
addressed to the fictional Peter when
the New York Times explained the story
in 2002 they also discovered that 19
Ingram Street was formed to a family
named Osborne just one letter off from
Spider-Man's arch nemesis Norman Osborne
Back in Black when he's not wearing his
red and blue Duds Spider-Man is known
for wearing a stealthy and slimming
black which he found in an alien vending
machine during 1984's Secret Wars
miniseries and decided to slap on his
body what readers might not know is that
the black costume wasn't an original
idea from Marvel but one sent in by a
fan for a contest in 1982. while Randy
Schuler's costume idea apparently
involved underarm webbing which didn't
make it into the sketch and a red logo
the similarities to the official black
suit remain Schuler was paid for his
idea 220 dollars which would be about
550 today Schuler's other ideas would
later be incorporated into additional
Spidey costume ideas unstable molecules
and thought control were both used by
spidey's Future Foundation and iron
spider costumes respectively but Schuler
was never given any actual credit
according to his own post on comic book
resources center of the web comics fans
might not think about it much but
Spider-Man is the absolute center of the
Marvel Multiverse even though Heroes
like Captain America and Iron Man get
top billing there are more versions of
Spider-Man across the Multiverse than
any other hero and anytime we visit
another reality Spider-Man is so iconic
and consistent that he's always there
and generally used as a compass to
differentiate the different planes of
existence while the main Marvel
continuity Earth 616 has its own fair
share of the spideys there are literally
hundreds of alternates including spider
ham of Earth 8311 the Flaming
stall-headed ghost spider of Earth 11638
and a whole lot of dead Spider-Man since
Peter seems to get caught in the old bug
zapper of Life pretty often the cruelest
revenge Spider-Man has probably had the
roughest life of any superhero he
doesn't have Batman's wealth and he
doesn't have Superman's strength but he
accomplishes pretty much the same heroic
stuff but the very worst thing that ever
happened to Spider-Man was being cheated
on by his girlfriend Gwen Stacy with his
arch nemesis Norman Osborne AKA The
Green Goblin while this was never spoken
of during Gwen's life the 1999 storyline
since past revealed the ultimate
betrayal Gwen had kept her terrible
Goblin baby secret and because of their
unique DNA they aged rapidly and came
after Peter Parker because that's what
goblins do everyone Peter Parker and
comic readers included hated the whole
thing spider magic everyone knows that
Spider-Man's powers are purely
scientific in nature because being bit
by a radioactive animal automatically
transfers its powers to you that's just
basic biology except in 2001 the arrival
of a character named Ezekiel revealed
that spidey's superhuman abilities were
actually kind of magic and that fateful
radioact active spider bit Peter Parker
on purpose because of cosmic mystical
machinations it's a bit like the
midichlorians of the Marvel Universe but
it also kind of explains why most of
spidey's bad guys are animal themed deal
with the Devil the Apex of weird
Spider-Man storylines is Peter Parker's
deal with the devil Mephisto in exchange
for the survival of his dear decrepit
nearly deceased anyway Aunt May spiny
would give up his marriage and future
kids with Mary Jane forcing him straight
back into the friend zone spidey's
reason for taking this deal Peter's Aunt
May was hovering between life and death
because she'd been put in danger after
he revealed his secret identity during
Civil War and he'd come to the sensible
conclusion that taking off his mask in
front of the world had been a big
mistake in return for Peter sacrificing
his life with Mary Jane Mephisto made
the world forget he was Spider-Man thus
protecting his loved ones from the line
of super villain fire crossover Madness
Spidey is a guy who gets around in some
pretty weird places in 1978 Peter and
Mary Jane attend a taping of Saturday
Night Live and a mix-up between villain
Silver Samurai and John Belushi's
Samurai character causes an issue long
Ruckus featuring the entire 1978 SNL
cast in 1993 Marvel had the rights to
publish a comic series based on Ren and
Stimpy so Spider-Man ended up battling
powdered toast men in those pages and
getting one punch through a wall by the
red-headed hero and in 2009 Spider-Man
rescues none other than Barack Obama
from the chameleon who decides to
impersonate the president-elect moments
before the inauguration and that's truly
only the tip of the weird bird so many
spiders at one point in Marvel's history
Spider-Man was so popular that he
starred in four books at once making it
nearly impossible to keep track of his
adventures or even take a nap all of it
came to a head when Norman Osborne
framed Spider-Man for murder forcing
Parker to drop his heroic Persona and
take on a different heroic mantle 4-4 as
Hornet and Prodigy Peter continued his
heroics and as Dusk and Ricochet he was
able to infiltrate New York's criminal
underworld to find the real murderer
Spidey was able to drop his alternate
identities but they were later Taken up
by a group called The Slingers who were
quickly beaten by the new Warriors in a
game of basketball and pretty much never
seen again Mary Jane is not my lover at
some point during the 1990s pop star
Michael Jackson made moves to try and
purchase Marvel Comics only because he
wanted to play a heroic character when
it came time to make some Marvel movies
it was revealed in 2011 that Jackson
petitioned X-Men's producers for the
role of Professor X for reasons that are
now a complete mystery to all Humanity
but Stan Lee's recollection was
different in their personal
conversations Jackson revealed to Lee
that he really wanted to play Spider-Man
though Toby Maguire eventually got the
role probably saving the Marvel movie
universe as we know it trailer trashed
speaking of the original 2002 Spider-Man
the film's original theatrical trailer
had to be completely he pulled and
scrapped after the events of 9 11. due
to the fact that the entire thing hinged
upon a helicopter being caught on a web
between the Twin Towers since the
terrorist attacks happened after much of
filming was completed but before the
film's theatrical release the towers
were cut from a handful of scenes the
replacement trailer featured Spider-Man
perching on an American flag instead
spandex sadness Spider-Man's many
portrayers have all had very different
reactions to the tights Civil War
Spider-Man Tom Holland had costumes that
were designed for his stunt double so
when he put them on they were a bit too
baggy bumming out Holland during his
first time in the suit according to
comic book movie Toby Maguire was pretty
uncomfortable until the costume
designers put in a bathroom portal and
despite bathroom breaks being a known
problem for spider actors the costume
Department again forgot to include a
vital flap for Andrew Garfield who only
had the addition put in during his
second outing as the character still
Garfield admitted during a radio
interview that he was so taken by the
fact that he got to play the iconic hero
that he cried when he first put on the
suit and we thought Toby was the Spidey
who cried turn off the dark Spider-Man's
films aren't the only times he's been
made into a live-action hero in 2010
director Julie tamore brought Spidey to
Broadway in a place so fraught with
problems that it quickly became an
unintentional Comedy of Errors even with
music by the members of U2 by opening
day the production had already cost 65
million dollars and not even Disney who
had recently purchased Marvel had any
interest in helping out a disturbing
number of actors and extras were injured
during production due to the show's
complex stunts and at one point Green
Goblin became stuck on a wire over the
audience hanging there for a few minutes
before the show could begin again not
even the clone saga was this
embarrassing spider's Sentai Broadway
wasn't the only place to suffer from a
misguided live-action Spider-Man in 1978
Japanese production company toei took
note of spidey's tight costume and
likened him to their own skin-tight
tokusatsu Heroes like Kamen Rider Japan
Spider-Man was given An Origin not
unlike DC's Green Lantern when he's
given a fancy device and Powers by an
alien from the planet spider who he
finds in a crashed UFO called marveler
in true Japan form Spidey also gets a
transforming robot which he uses to
fight against Professor monster the show
ran for 41 episodes all with Marvel's
approval and with amazing episode titles
like becoming Splendid to the murderous
machine of transformation and the onion
silver mask and the boys detective group
Spiderman animation in 1992 Marvel and
Savon had a huge hit with their X-Men
animated series so Marvel decided to
build on the success by debuting
Spider-Man in 1994 while Spidey series
was also an action figure spawning
phenomenon it was subject to completely
absurd censorship while it's reasonable
to request that a kid's cartoon omit
animated blood it made less sense to
forbid even the mention of blood even in
an episode where morbius the living
vampire appears and can no longer be
called a vampire other rules included no
breaking glass no punching except in
limited circumstances and no use of the
word sinister this last one is
especially Odd as spidey's main villain
Collective is known as The Sinister Six
and Mr Sinister was over on X-Men being
evil on the regular sorry kids basic
English vocabulary is too rough for your
little pudding brains and bloodless
bodies say no to bugs because Spidey is
pretty much an everyday average guy he's
been used countless times as a tool for
educational purposes from direct to VHS
shorts about child abuse to full comic
arcs about the dangers of drugs when the
US government approached Stan Lee to
write an anti-drug story in 1971 he was
all for it as long as it was a good
story strangely enough this was during a
time when the comics code Authority also
expressly forbade any mention of drugs
whatsoever after the story was shot down
by the comics code Lee made the
difficult decision to publish it anyway
it was so well received that the CCA
changed its own code opening up Comics
to a much wider range of educational
stories oh baby spidey's strangest foray
into educational materials was
definitely the pull of The Prodigy a
1976 story written by Anne Robinson for
Planned Parenthood in an amazingly
surreal plot the alien villain called
Prodigy no relation to Spider-Man's
previously mentioned alter Alter Ego
uses the powers of alien persuasion to
try to convince teenagers to make babies
so that he'll have tons of minions to do
his bidding part of The Prodigy's
propaganda was to straight up say that
diseases weren't possible and getting
down in the back seat of a Chevy didn't
really cause pregnancies of course
Spidey laments how tough his life is
even without a Rugrat and defeats The
Prodigy before it's too late if anyone
was poised to lecture kids about
celibacy it was definitely nerdy Peter
Parker
with so many Spider-Man movies out there
there are a lot of Spider-Man villains
we're taking a look back at the many
many super villains that spidey's
battled against beware some gigantic
spoilers ahead stop the video now if
you're not up to date on every spider
movie The Amazing Spider-Man 2 is even
more than Spider-Man 3 before it an
overstuffed movie that banks on
interconnectivity to help Drive
excitement for a sequel that ultimately
never came at the time Sony Pictures was
attempting to push ahead with its own
Cinematic Universe with Spider-Man at
the heart when it didn't work we ended
up with Spider-Man in the MCU watching
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 today is mostly
in a museum exercise and seeing someone
try to build a universe that never quite
comes together Rhino is sadly a victim
of this crumbling effort the film had
Paul Giamatti playing a Russian gangster
in a mechanical Rhino suit and the actor
clearly relished chewing up as much
scenery as he possibly could in the role
sadly he only appears in a couple of
scenes he might have had more to do with
a hypothetical sequel but here he's
largely an example of a wasted
opportunity the version of Green Goblin
who shows up in The Amazing Spider-Man 2
is a perfect example of the film pushing
ahead for Universe building while
sacrificing any real sense of long-term
storytelling we've never met this
version of Harry Osborne before but
we're told he's got a connection to
Peter going back years we haven't seen
the toll as genetic illness is taking on
him but we're told it's bad and we
should care we haven't seen any real
development in terms of Green Goblin
Tech but we're shown it all packaged and
ready for Harry to dive in it's a whole
lot of telling without any emotional
weight this lack of real investment
makes this the most forgettable version
of Green Goblin on the big screen so far
making Electro the primary villain of
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 was a good idea
on paper he's got cool powers that can
manifest themselves in interesting ways
visually and it was played by Jamie Foxx
who offered up a new version of the
character unfortunately it doesn't quite
work box seemed to do the best he could
with the material he had but the
character's motivations get law lost in
the shuffle of everything else the film
is trying to do by the time Electro is
somehow actually playing music with his
powers at the end of the film he's lost
any good will he had before
foreign
[Music]
Venom is a complicated character and
introducing him into any film as a
Spider-Man antagonist has the potential
to be very tricky business the way
Spider-Man 3 does it works fine as a
catalyst for the film's climax but
doesn't really let audiences get to know
this particular version of the villain
and how he works there's no time to dig
into what the relationship to the
Symbiote is or exactly why Eddie Brock
gives in so quickly or if there's any
real Humanity left in him this version
of Venom is pretty much just a fight
scene man that's a shame
Spider-Man homecoming the first solo
Spider-Man Adventure in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is a great example of
a film that knows how to juggle multiple
villains without overwhelming the piece
while vulture does the heavy lifting as
the film's chief bad guy his crew back
at headquarters fits into the story in
an organic and entertaining way however
the tinkerer doesn't rank higher on this
list because he doesn't have that much
to do in the film he's the guy in the
chair manipulating Tech and
Communications behind the scenes while
the vulture does the fighting because of
that he's not a heavy hitter within the
film but he's certainly entertaining in
the space he's given homecoming manages
to breathe real life into him by making
him a nosy strange guy who's just happy
to have a gig where he can be a huge
tech nerd let me tell you about looking
at my phone oh sorry you left it out you
know I'm a curious person by Nature
the economy of Storytelling in
homecoming is so great that the film
manages to fit in not one but two
versions of the Shocker in the film he's
an employee of the vulture who's gifted
with gauntlets and emit tremendous
energy when they make contact with
someone or something it's enough to make
the character stand out in his few fight
scenes the first shocker relishes the
idea that he can have a self-giving code
name and go around punching things with
his new toys you're out there wearing
that goofy thing lighting up cars
calling yourself the Shocker of the
Shocker a shock people what is this pro
wrestling yeah whatever old man when the
second shocker gets a hold of the
gauntlets Things become much more
business-like and the deliberate
calculated way in which he tries to pick
apart Peter Parker is actually rather
chilling together they present A
Portrait of a minor super villain that
adds plenty to the film while never
getting in the way of vulture's
Spotlight The Amazing Spider-Man wisely
started its new Spidey Universe by
picking a villain who'd only been hinted
at in the Sam Raimi films in the form of
a supporting character we'd seen Dr Kirk
Connors before 4 but we'd never seen him
transformed into a monster by his own
scientific hubris and Desperation the
fact that the character was in the Ramey
films created a sense of excitement
among fans who were finally going to get
to see the lizard while never quite
feeling like the new film was retracing
the steps of the old ones in The Amazing
Spider-Man Dr Connors takes on a certain
kind of quiet strangeness that permeates
the early scenes you get the sense that
he's a man who's thought far too much
about things he probably shouldn't be
tinkering with as his slow
transformation Begins the character
becomes even stranger creating a villain
who's both threatening and sympathetic
[Music]
the decision to make the Sandman a major
villain in Spider-Man 3 is an
interesting one particularly when you
consider all the other things the film
is trying to do with Peter Parker's
emotional Journey the decision to make
him the guy who killed Uncle Ben off
screen in the first film complicates
this in ways that neither the film nor
the Spider-Man Mythos really need
despite this this version of the Sandman
works because of the parallels the film
draws between him and Peter they're both
men with strange Powers they didn't ask
for pushed into darkness by
circumstances beyond their control and
hoping to atone for their past mistakes
Thomas Hayden Church plays the character
with real hearts and his final scene is
one of the most powerful moments in a
flawed film
I'm not asking you to forgive me
I just want you to understand
Spider-Man 3 could have been a film
entirely about the rise of a second
Green Goblin in parallel to Peter Parker
wrestling with the Venom symbiote and it
would have still been a jam-packed movie
as it is we got a film that attempted to
juggle three different villains and cram
them all together into a final fight
scene so Harry Osborne's final journey
in the Spider-Man trilogy gets crammed
in too still Perry's decision to become
the second Green Goblin in an effort to
avenge his father and then to seek
heroic Redemption is a rewarding one it
doesn't always work particularly when
Harry has to turn on a dime between hero
and villain in various scenes but the
two preceding films add emotional weight
to a weaker script
Defoe is having so much fun in the role
of Green Goblin years before character
actors would begin competing for super
villain roles left and right that his
sense of instant Joy at being immersed
in the comic book world is infectious
the foe has to transform into full super
villain mode almost instantly and
somehow he brings it to life flawlessly
what do you want
to say what you want to do what you
can't
he does so even in spite of the film's
shortcomings and its treatment of the
character something that's particularly
obvious in a costume design the decision
to forego an expressive face for the
character and instead feature a Fang
bearing mask might have made sense in
2002. unfortunately watching the film
today it makes the scenes with
Spider-Man and the Goblin look a bit too
much like action figures yelling at each
other even in those moments though
depoe's voice carries the performance if
you didn't watch the intro this is where
the big spoilers happen so turn back now
Spider-Man far from home had to follow a
lot of different very tough acts just
one of which was Michael Keaton's
performance as the vulture the decision
to make the next villain Mysterio
another newcomer to live action
Spider-Man was a welcome one even better
fans seemed to immediately support Jake
Gyllenhaal's cast in his Mysterio a guy
who creates Illusions to disguise his
true intentions Gyllenhaal gets a lot of
meaty stuff to play with in the pill
from the idea that he first presents
himself as a hero From Another Dimension
to the Revelation that he's a scorned
former employee of Tony Stark the early
more heroic scenes work great but the
turn is where Gyllenhaal really shines
once the gloves are off and he's in full
super villain mode he's having the time
of his life and so are we he doesn't
quite rise to the heights of the very
best live-action Spider-Man villains but
he's very close so much so that even
after far from home you can't help but
feel hungry for more of him
with a few notable exceptions Sam
raimi's Spider-Man films are often
defined by their aesthetic and
structural Devotion to the Marvel Comics
book they're based on the key to the
best of these films is the way in which
they know exactly how to deviate and win
with Spider-Man 2 we get the best of
both worlds and Dr Octopus he's a guy
who looks and moves exactly how we'd
expect the comic book version to move
and he has the added gravitas of a good
man corrupted by his own creation Alfred
Molina is Flawless as Dr octo Octavius a
scientist who's hoping to change the
world before his brain is infected by
the artificial intelligence in his
robotic extra arms after a horrible
accident riddled with guilt and grief
Molina plays the disintegration of the
character perfectly then manages to
guide him back to Redemption with the
same sense of vulnerability and delicate
emotional resonance it's a great
performance and a great comic book movie
Sometimes Spider-Man's stories are at
their very best when they take a very
simple easy to follow metaphor and
translate it into the big bold Strokes
of a superhero story Spider-Man
homecoming is a story about Peter Parker
finding out his girlfriend's dad is a
jerk and the jerk is played to
Perfection by Michael Keaton there's so
much to love about the vulture and
homecoming from the look of the
character to the way Keaton plays him as
a working-class guy who got tired of
being pushed around there's no nonsense
here but there are tricky emotional
turns to make and Keaton manages them
all by being equal parts charming and
terrifying the scene in which he has a
private moment with Peter in his car is
among the best moments in any Spider-Man
film
hey
hey just saved your life
thank you even better the fact that his
character actually has a point about the
way regular people are pushed down in an
increasingly strange world only adds to
his impact it's a brilliant layered
performance that's going to be hard to
top
[Music]
a lot of people keep making movies about
a guy who shoots webs out of his wrists
because they're fun and that's not just
true for the audience the people making
them seem to be having a blast too here
are some times when things got a little
silly on set
in Spider-Man homecoming Tom Holland's
Peter Parker has a full and busy life in
addition to superheroics he's got to
juggle homework with a spot on his
school's academic team not to mention
working as an intern at Stark Industries
in one scene he tries to talk his way
out of an upcoming Academic Decathlon
and his advisor won't take no for an
answer Peter split us up a list of his
responsibilities and it turns out that
responsibilities are something of a
trigger word it's the Crux of a
Spider-Man Mantra after all when he
flubs the line he can't help but break
character give a right turn to the
camera and recite the phrase predecessor
Toby Maguire made mainstream Stark and
my internship you know I got a lot of
responsibility with it
with great power here comes great
responsibility when Spider-Man 2 opens
Peter Parker has already endured a lot
of Spider-Man he's in college at this
point but still the same clumsy guy in
public picking up none of the
gracefulness of a superhero side in one
scene Peter drops all of his books and
school supplies while walking on campus
That was supposed to happen but came as
a surprise that Toby Maguire was what
happened next as he stays in character
grumbling and picking up his things as
other students walk by one faceless
extra slams her backpack into Maguire's
head and catches a strap on his neck
this blooper is actually a prank
courtesy of director Sam Remy he's the
guy with the backpack surprising Maguire
and making him laugh
oh
my God well Spider-Man isn't as loaded
as Batman or powerful as Superman he
does have one big thing in common with
them he's an orphan those other guys
were raised by a butler and some kindly
Farmers while Spider-Man grew into a
goofy and friendly teen thanks to his
Aunt May and Uncle Ben in a rapid fire
barrage of bloopers from the set of
Spider-Man homecoming Ned played by
Jacob batalan and Peter tried to talk to
Liz about the current team party scene
and Peter mentions how parents sometimes
let their kids throw those parties that
bit of dialogue sends Holland off the
rails he remembers that his character
doesn't exactly have biological parents
anymore they let you have parties you
know my parents are dead
a quiet heartfelt moment with the object
of your affection can make even the most
confident person into a tongue-tied mess
but hey sometimes deep thoughts and
feelings are better left instead right
that would make one Spider-Man 2 blooper
extremely realistic except Toby Maguire
isn't supposed to be so worthlessly for
mucks in a cute romantic scene with
Kirsten Dunst who's playing Mary Jane
Watson
all right to his credit he sells that
mistake as simply being overwhelmed by
emotion but then he realizes he's been
silent for way too long and that The Jig
Is Up
part of what makes Spider-Man such a
great character are the differences
between the Bold superhero and his
mold-mannered alter ego Spider-Man is
Peter Parker of course but they're also
total opposites at least to the Casual
Observer for example Spider-Man Glides
through the air with the greatest of
ease Peter Parker on the other hand is a
gangly and timid teen who's not quite
comfortable in his own skin in
Spider-Man homecoming the actor meant to
embody both Peter and Spider-Man really
nailed Peter Parker's awkwardness Tom
Holland is almost too deep in character
the actor apparently tripped slipped and
stumbled quite a lot during the making
of the movie
Toby Maguire feels uncomfortable doing
romantic scenes and action-heavy
superhero movies or maybe he doesn't
think the idea of introducing the comics
character Gwen Stacy is necessary for
the already overstuffed Spider-Man 3
which already had so many characters or
maybe the actor has just gone a little
Stir Crazy from playing Spider-Man in
three movies over five years whatever
the reason maguirecon seemed to get
through filming close-up coverage and
what's supposed to be a simple Exchange
in which Gwen introduces herself to the
Daily Bugle photographer
and action hi Peter hi
was that the blonde wig
Spider-Man's web swinging is a special
effect achieved with some combination of
green screen CGI and actors suspended
from gravity-defying wires being
harnessed up like that is not exactly a
natural or comfortable state it takes a
lot of effort to get used to let alone
do a good job of acting in that
condition on the set of Spider-Man
homecoming Tom Holland couldn't seem to
get the hang of those dangling wires he
tries to turn his inability to navigate
the wires into a little dance in front
of his concerned co-star Donald Glover
hey are you all right man
a more wire-based Shenanigans while
shooting a night scene for Spider-Man 3
Tobey Maguire guides Kirsten Dunst down
to the safety of the ground while
notably not wearing a Spidey suit Dunst
has so much fun with The Descent that
she lets out a couple of foods which
seemingly causes Maguire to forget his
line he improvises some silliness
instead
let's go get on my bike okay
in Avengers Infinity War when Thanos
snaps half the universe to death
Spider-Man falls into the arms of his
mentor Tony Stark before turning to dust
it's heartbreaking which means Holland
probably wanted to keep things lined and
bouncy when his character miraculously
returns an Avengers endgame in fact the
actor literally bounces around the
rubble stream set much to the pleasure
of Downey Jr who hugs the Boy Wonder for
just a little too long and even plans a
kiss on his cheek welcome back wall
crawler
since his debut in 1962 Spider-Man has
been one of the most popular superheroes
in the world and he's also one of the
most well-known but with countless
Spider-Man stories built around some
pretty confusing plot points it's easy
to get mixed up let us have the great
responsibility of clearing up a lot of
incorrect things people believe about
Spider-Man
of all the original Marvel Universe
titles The Amazing Spider-Man is one of
the most strongly identified with Stan
the Man Lee even though he'd be a part
of all of Marvel's early string of hits
including the Avengers the X-Men the
Hulk and more Spidey was the character
he stuck with the longest scripting the
first 100 issues and then staying on
sporadically for another few years after
you know I guess one person can make a
difference
enough said
however you think Stan's the only one
responsible for the Thrills of those
Early Adventures you're mistaken most
fans are aware that Lee pioneered the
Marvel style of writing in which she'd
collaborate with an artist on a loose
plot then add in the dialogue after
everything else was done with a little
less well-known however is that his
relationship with artist and
Spider-Man's co-creator Steve ditko was
one of the first to deteriorate
according to Marvel Comics The Untold
Story the latter chunk of dickco's 38
issue run including the legendary story
that gave the world the iconic image of
Spider-Man fighting his way out from
under a massive heap of rubble was
produced without dick cohenley speaking
to each other at all foreign
[Music]
of course that doesn't mean Lane wasn't
a necessary ingredient for Spider-Man's
early success the fact that he stayed
with the character for almost seven
years after ditko's departure and kept
on producing some of the best years of
Spider-Man is a testament to how
important he was to the character and
how well he got along with ditko's
replacement Jazzy John romita
the one thing about Spider-Man that's
always been true is that underneath that
mask is always Peter Parker just an
average everyday scientific super genius
with problems just like ours you know
like juggling our long-term
relationships to supermodels while
making a living off selfies that's why
it's always been Peter except for all
those times it's someone else while
Peter Parker has certainly been the main
man in the mask at Spider-Man since
spidey's debut in 1962 he's definitely
not the only one for a while in the 90s
Spider-Man was instead Ben Riley a clone
of Peter made by a villain called The
Jackal right around the time Peter
temporarily lost his powers Riley was
tricked into thinking he was the genuine
article he dyed his hair blonde got a
job at a coffee shop and took over the
role with a new costume for the entirety
of 1996 before eventually dissolving
into a pile of dust more recently Peter
found his own Consciousness overwritten
by Dr Octopus who took over his life as
The Superior Spider-Man Beyond just
variations on Peter Parker's body and
enough alternate universe versions that
they have their own special team there's
a an entirely different Spider-Man in
the Marvel Universe Miles Morales who
stepped into the spotlight in 2018's
into the spider-verse a movie based
entirely on teaching us that anyone
could be Spider-Man if they never give
up including Gwen Stacy Nick Cage and a
talking pig
it can get weirder
one of the most intense arguments you
could overhear in a comic book store
back when the first Spider-Man movie
came out concerned whether Spider-Man's
web shooters were mechanical or an
organic byproduct of his spider powers
going by the comics though it doesn't
matter what side of the argument you're
on you're wrong either way when Sam
raimi's film hit theaters one of the few
notable changes that it made to
Spider-Man's origin story came with the
addition of organic web shooters this
proved to be so controversial that when
the next movies were announced in 2010
the decision to use the comics
mechanical web shooters literally made
headlines after all he'd never had
organic web shooters in the comics or at
least he didn't have them in the comics
before those movies came out after their
success a 2005 storyline called the
other ended with Peter being eaten by a
giant spider and emerging with Organic
webs those didn't last either they
inexplicably disappeared with the Back
to Basics approach of the Brand New Day
story two years later but other Marvel
Universe spider characters retained them
in fact Cindy Moon a classmate of Peters
who was bitten by the same reading video
active spider is so capable of spinning
her own webs that her super heroic code
name became silk
one of the defining tragedies of
Spider-Man's life was the death of Gwen
Stacy in the 60s she was the love of
Peter Parker's life forming a
complicated love triangle with Mary Jane
Watson and providing the backbone of the
soap opera that underscored his Spidey
superheroics an Amazing Spider-Man
number 121 the Green Goblin kidnapped
her and used her as bait to lure
Spider-Man into a battle at the top of
the George Washington Bridge and while
the story title wasn't revealed into the
last page the night Gwen Stacy died
lived up to its name the goblin is
definitely to blame for Gwen's murder
he's the one who took her to the top of
the bridge and the one who threw her off
all in an effort to torture Spider-Man
if however you really want to get
technical about things he's not the one
responsible for what literally killed
her that sad honor goes to Spider-Man
himself it's easy to miss but the real
tragedy can be seen in the issue when
Spider-Man tried to save Guin by
snagging her leg with a web line as she
plunged toward the Hudson River the
sudden stop proved to be the Fatal
moment a small snap sound effect next to
Gwyn shows it was a broken neck from
Peter's attempt at saving her that
actually ended Quinn's life
Spider-Man doesn't kill it's one of the
absolute rules of the character and
unlike other Heroes he's lived up to it
too in over 50 years of comics
Spider-Man has never actually killed
anyone himself except for the one time
he did it happened in the pages of
Spider-Man vs Wolverine a 1987 one shot
by Christopher priest and Mark bright
that pulled Spidey into a dark world of
international Espionage the conflict
between the two title characters is
largely built around a spy code named
Charlemagne who is described as
Wolverine's best friend from his days as
a government operative in this story
Charlie wants Wolverine to kill her so
she won't be apprehended and spend the
rest of her life being tortured in a
gulag when Spider-Man stumbles into this
situation all he knows is Wolverine is
trying to kill someone in the fight that
ensues Spidey unleashes his full
strength on the X-Men hitting him with
blows that would wreck cars sadly
Charlie takes advantage of the brutal
conflict tricking Spider-Man into
hitting her instead of Wolverine using
him to commit suicide he Peter was
understandably traumatized by the event
and while he and Wolverine have made
peace in the year since it was a source
of bitterness between them for a long
time
the iconic image of Peter Parker is of a
young man struggling to make ends meet
by working as a freelance photographer
selling snapshots of his own Super
heroic exploits to the Daily Bugle to
satisfy J Jonah Jameson's demand for
pictures of Spider-Man if that's your
only concept of what Spidey does when
he's not out fighting crime however it's
time for an update the truth is while
Peter worked for the bugle for decades
in a lot of classic stories he hasn't
actually been a freelance photographer
for most of this Century starting in
2001 Pete returned to his old stomping
grounds of Midtown high as a science
teacher but that proved to be a pretty
short-lived career choice in the years
since he's had a couple of
science-related jobs working for a think
tank called Horizon Labs where he
reverse engineered his crime-fighting
gadgets into consumer goods he even
founded his own Multinational
Corporation Called Parker Industries
although technically it was Otto
Octavius who founded that company while
he was in Peter's body and Peter had to
destroy it to keep it from being taken
over by Nazis Comics are complicated
one of the more controversial moments in
Spider-Man's Comics history involved a
deal with the devil like the literal
devil not just this guy
after Peter revealed his identity during
the events of Civil War his family was
targeted by bad guys who nearly killed
Aunt May which was a good reminder of
why he had the whole secret identity
thing to begin with unfortunately for
the Parker family that sort of reveal
isn't the kind of thing you can undo
unless you're willing to make an
infernal bargain with Mephisto which is
exactly what happened rather than
selling their souls however Peter and
then wife Mary Jane Watson sold their
marriage effectively erasing their years
of wedded bliss from Marvel Comics
continuity as though it had never
happened in a Spider-Man comics Peter
and MJ were both freed up to pursue new
relationships but don't let that fool
you into thinking the marriage is
completely gone in order to go along
with the comic book storyline the
Spider-Man newspaper strip did away with
the marriage as well readers reacted so
poorly however that in the strip that
ran on May 24 2009 the elimination of
the marriage was revealed to have been a
dream ever since newspaper Spidey has
remained happily married or at least as
happy as anyone can be when they spend
most of their time getting knocked
unconscious right next to Dilbert
everyone knows that Peter Parker was
orphaned at a young age and raised by
Aunt May and Uncle Ben considering that
his surrogate parents were about as
wholesome and salt of the earth as
people could be it stands to reason that
Richard and Mary Parker were cut from
the same cloth just average ordinary
folks right
wrong in 1968 it was revealed that when
the Parker parents died they were under
a cloud of Suspicion as traitors to
their country the truth however was that
they were spies working for shield who
had infiltrated the red skull's criminal
organization before being killed without
ever getting the chance to clear their
names yes in case you missed that
Spider-Man's parents were spies who were
murdered by Captain America's arch
nemesis if that's not weird enough they
later turned up alive only to be
revealed even later to be robot
duplicates that's not the end of the
Parker family's Secrets though it turns
out that in addition to the parents he
never knew Spidey also had a long-lost
older sister Teresa who was herself a
shield agent after a team up in which it
was revealed that her memories of The
Parkers were falsely implanted by
Mephisto it turned out that was also a
ruse she was in fact Peter's actual
sister after all and even pitched in to
help him fight bad guys using her spy
skills
if you've ever read any Spider-Man comic
or seen him in a movie or a cartoon or
encountered the character pretty much
anywhere then you've almost certainly
seen the motto that guides his life
power
except Ben Parker never actually said
those words in Amazing Fantasy number 15
spidey's often referenced motto is never
spoken Out Loud by any character not
even Uncle Ben instead it only appears
in a caption at the end of the story as
a moral lesson imparted by well Stan Lee
Spidey himself doesn't even say it until
25 years later in 1987 as time went on
though the phrase became more and more
identified with Ben largely because it
would be really weird for Spider-Man to
solemnly vow to accept the lesson that
was imparted to him through narration by
the guy who wrote his comics
Spider-Man has faced nearly every member
of his Rogues Gallery during his
cinematic adventures but there are still
a few villains who have yet to make
their Silver Screen debut from killer
goblins to monstrous vampires to
um swarms of bees these are a few of
those villains
Craven the hunter is by far the most
infamous Spider-Man villain to have
never featured in a live-action movie
otherwise known as Sergey cravenov this
obsessive Big Game Hunter first appeared
all the way back in 1964's Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 15. in this
story Craven is hired by his friend
chameleon to bring down Spider-Man
inevitably the hunter quickly becomes
the prey and Spider-Man has Craven both
arrested and deported this would Mark
the beginning of a long and storied
criminal career for Sergey cravenov who
has devoted his entire existence to
besting Spider-Man once and for all
considering Craven is such a prominent
member of Spider-Man's Rogues Gallery
it'll come as no surprise to find the
fans have been clamoring for him to show
up on screen for many years
and he's come pretty close too in 2021
Tom Holland even told collider that
Spider-Man no way home director John
Watts originally intended for the third
MCU Spidey movie to feature Craven as
the main antagonist and now it seems
that Craven is finally about to step
into the spotlight a solo film set
within Sony's Spider-Man universe has
been on the cards for a while now and in
2021 deadline reported that Avengers Age
of Ultron star Aaron Taylor Johnson had
been cast as the notorious Hunter
himself you didn't see that coming
should all go to plan Craven the hunter
will land in theaters on January 13 2023
Goblin villains will be very familiar to
fans of the Spider-Man movies Willem
Dafoe made comic book movie history as
Norman Osborne's Green Goblin in the
original Spider-Man while James Franco
played Harry as born in Sam raimi's
Trilogy taking the mantle of new Goblin
in Spider-Man 3. similarly Dane Dahan
played a goblin crazed Harry Osborne in
the Amazing Spider-Man 2. in the comics
however there are far more goblins than
the Green Goblin and many more people
have taken the mantle than Norman and
Harry Osborne perhaps the second most
well known of these is the villain known
as the Hobgoblin six people have
operated under that name over the years
but the deadliest of all is Roderick
Kingsley debuting as the masked villain
in 1983's Amazing Spider-Man Vol 1
number 238 Kingsley is a billionaire
fashion designer who enters the criminal
underworld after acquiring and altering
Norman Osborne's Goblin formula it's
probably fair to say that audiences are
probably over the Green Goblin by now
despite Willem dafoe's dramatic return
in Spider-Man no way home nevertheless
the hobgoblins movie debut could provide
a refreshing Twist on a fan favorite
villain
otherwise known as the spot Jonathan own
first appeared in 1985's Peter Parker
The Spectacular Spider-Man Vol 1 number
98 a scientist in the employee of
Kingpin own creates a strange black
portal while attempting to recreate the
powers of the vigilante hero Khloe it
soon becomes clear that own has gained
the ability to open these portals and
Traverse physical space via the
so-called spot world own subsequently
names himself the spot and embarks upon
a criminal career the spot's unique
costume and strange abilities make him a
more visually arresting villain than
most suitably he's featured in a number
of stories beyond the comic book
Universe including Spider-Man the
Animated Series and the 2017 Spider-Man
show it's possible he'll be popping up
on the Silver Screen sometime soon too
as according to Murphy's Multiverse the
spot could be a key Baddie in the
upcoming animated sequel Spider-Man
across the spider-verse this could
literally not get any weirder since the
comic version of own is a close Ally of
Kingpin who was the main antagonist in
into the spider-verse it's easy to see
how he might fit into Miles Morales
story and how the spot's
interdimensional Powers could provide an
intriguing slant on the original movies
Multiverse Atlantics
the inheritors are a team of super
villains best known for their role in
the original spider-verse story arc and
its follow-up spider gedden each member
of this clan of totem hunting vampires
has dedicated their life to hunting down
spider people across the Multiverse and
consuming their Essences a number of
inheritors have battled Spider-Man and
his other selves but the two most
prominent are Moreland and Karn Morlan
is arguably the deadliest and scariest
member of the inheritors having killed
and consumed a whole heap of spider
people during his so-called great hunt
Carn meanwhile is living in Exile during
his first appearance after he hesitated
on a mission to capture the master
Weaver who controls the all-powerful web
of life and Destiny karn's mother was
struck down and killed as a result Karn
was exiled until he could prove his
return a task he attempts to accomplish
throughout the first spider-verse
storyline
as the main antagonists of the comic
book version of spider-verse it seems
strange that the inheritors had nothing
to do with Spider-Man into the
spider-verse still with two follow-ups
planned for that movie who knows what
the future has in store for these
Dimension hopping ghouls
silver Sable is one of those Spider-Man
characters who can act as an ally or an
enemy of the wall crawler depending on
what each story requires born Sylvia
sablinova this highly skilled mercenary
was introduced in 1985's Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 265 in which she
leads the Vigilante team of soldiers
known as the wild pack although she has
collaborated with a number of
superheroes over the years including
Spider-Man silver Sable has still played
the role of antagonist every now and
that although sablenova has yet to star
in a Spider-Man movie The Character was
once destined for the big screen in 2017
Sony announced that production had begun
on silver and black a feature film
following the adventures of sable and
black cat another morally ambiguous
Spider-Man friend in foe sadly the
project wasn't destined to last and
director Gina Prince bikewood eventually
revealed that Sony were considering
offering the story to Disney plus having
previously decided to give each
character their own movie Project a few
months later Prince bathwood told Looper
that she'd been preoccupied with her
work on the Netflix movie The Old Guard
but that she was planning to re-engage
with the silver Sable and Black Cat
Project at some point still Marvel fans
shouldn't expect to see Sable gracing
the Silver Screen in the near future
the villain known as Mr negative is a
more recent addition to Spider-Man's
Rogues Gallery first hitting the page in
2007's Free Comic Book Day The Amazing
Spider-Man his true name isn't known but
the man who became Mr negative was once
a Chinese gangster captured by the Crime
Boss silvermane and forced to undergo an
experimental drug procedure this process
gave him control over the light force
and dark force two forms of extra
dimensional energy that are more
commonly wielded by mutants and Magic
users the experiment also split the
gangster's mind into two forming the
Martin Lee Persona a philanthropist who
works with the homeless as well as Mr
negative himself the evil crime Lord at
the head of the inner demons street gang
Mr negative has played a prominent role
in Spider-Man's stories in recent years
but one of his most famous occurs in the
Marvel's Spider-Man video game in which
he wages a war against Kingpin and
Norman Osborne for control of New York
what are you doing to me
obviously Mr negative isn't exactly a
stalwarts of the live-action Spider-Man
movies but his homeless charity Feast
appears in Spider-Man no way home so
Never Say Never
despite being nowhere near as well known
as Spider-Man's A-list Villains The
Jackal is actually one of Peter Barker's
oldest foes in 1965 The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 31 introduced
readers to Miles Warren a professor at
Empire State University Who develops A
desperate infatuation with the student
Gwen Stacy after Stacy is killed by the
Green Goblin Warren blames Spider-Man
for her death adopting The Jackal Alter
Ego in order to get his revenge the
jackal's true identity was actually
something of a Twist in the original
comic books his villainous Persona
didn't emerge until 1974's The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 129 with his
true identity revealed a year later in
number 148 in subsequent years the
Jackal has fought Spider-Man on a number
of occasions but his most notable
contribution is the creation of Clone
copies of Spider-Man such as Ben Reilly
who eventually became the Jackal himself
as such The Jackal is taken on a
starring role in some of Spider-Man's
most famous and Infamous story lines
including the clone saga and spider
Island
here's a pitch for you an Australian
with a knack for hurling boomerangs
Don's A Goofy costume and turns to a
life of crime joining up with several
super villain teams in the process think
you've heard this one before well this
isn't actually the origin of DC's
Captain Boomerang or at least it's not
just the origin of DC's Captain
Boomerang this is the story of Frederick
Myers AKA Boomerang DC's take on a
boomerang wielding criminal preceded
Marvels by six years with the latter
hitting the scene in 1966's Tales to
astonish volume 1 number 81 and it's
also probably fair to say that Marvel's
Boomerang is far less renowned than his
distinguished competitor Myers is an
ex-professional baseball player known
for his strong pitching arm who was
drafted into the employ of the
hydra-adjacent group known as the secret
Empire his new task Masters outfitted
him with special weapons and conferred
upon him the code name Boomerang more is
a joke than anything else after the end
of the Empire Myers decides to become a
freelance assassin and in this role he
has joined the ranks of pretty much
every team of super villains to have
ever existed sadly considering DC's
Captain Boomerang has recently been
adapted into live action for both
Suicide Squad movies it doesn't seem
likely that Marvel will be trying out
their own Boomerang anytime soon
let's just get one thing clear here yes
this is absolutely a man made of bees
better known under the pseudonym swarm
Fritz Von Meyer was a Nazi scientist who
stumbled across a colony of mutant bees
after the end of World War II Von Meyer
attempted and failed to control these
bees who consumed him alive and absorbed
him into their hive mind this not only
merged their consciousnesses but also
gave him the ability to control them at
will all of this is explained in
Champions Volume 1 Number 15. a story in
which swarm takes on a team of Heroes
including Angel Black Widow Ghost Rider
Hercules Iceman and Dark Star since then
however Von Meyer and his bothersome
bees have become a stalwart enemy of
Spider-Man more recently in Ant-Man Vol
2 he is teamed up with Scott Lang to
take down the buglords who are exactly
what they sound like as you might have
guessed swarm isn't exactly the most
serious comic book villain out there
indeed his latest stories have been a
lot of fun often leaning into the
characters Arch silliness if ever a
future Spider-Man movie needed a
colorful and amusing secondary
antagonist to stir up trouble on the
side swarm would be just the horrific
mass of bees for the job
Jackson wheel aka Big Wheel is one of
Spider-Man's weirdest foes first
appearing in 1978's The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 1 number 182 wheel is a
corrupt businessman who hires the
villainous engineer known as the
tinkerer to create a massive deadly mono
wheel that will help him to defeat his
rival rocket racer their Feud soon
brings the big wheel into the path of
Spider-Man sparking a rivalry that would
last well not very long at all wheel
actually disappears at the end of the
very next issue and has only returned a
few times mostly as a joke character he
has also dabbled in super heroics every
now and again and even his more recent
acts of Mischief have been half-hearted
at best big wheel has yet to turn up in
a live action adaptation of Spider-Man's
Adventures which you probably knew
already because who wouldn't have
remembered Andrew Garfield fleeing a
huge wheel in The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
still it's probably fair to say that
this guy needs to join the MCU ASAP cast
some highly prestigious A-list actor
throw him into battle against Peter
Parker and watch those box office
numbers soar
just because Peter Parker's Aunt May is
getting on a bit doesn't mean she's
boring in fact there's much more to May
than just a mean batch of wheat cakes
from her humble beginnings to her big
screen debut and everything in between
here's the untold story of Marvel's most
iconic golden oldie
officially Mae and Ben Parker made their
canonical debut alongside Spider-Man an
Amazing Fantasy number 15. but
Spider-Man's origin story wasn't the
first time that the characters had
graced the pages of a Marvel comic a
couple of months before Spider-Man's big
entrance Stan Lee and Steve ditko
published a short story called goodbye
to Linda Brown in Strange Tales number
97 which featured early versions of both
of Peter's relatives goodbye to Linda
Brown is only a few pages long and
doesn't leave much room for character
development but both Ben and may show
glimmers at their future selves for one
they look very similar to their Amazing
Fantasy counterparts especially May for
some reason the colorist decided to give
Ben a gray mustache although ditko
clearly didn't pencil one in in addition
both characters spend most of their time
predating over a teenager with secret
superpowers which is pretty much all
Aunt May did for the first 50 issues or
so of The Amazing Spider-Man luckily
things did get a little more interesting
after that
most fans probably saw ant May in the
flesh for the first time in Sam raimi's
2002 Spider-Man movie in which Peter
Parker's daughtering aunt was played by
emmy-winning actress Rosemary Harris but
Harris wasn't actually the first person
to bring May to life in a live-action
project that honor goes to Jeff Donald
and so were clear Jean-Marie Donald went
by her nickname Jeff so that explains
that anyway she portrayed Aunt May in a
90-minute TV movie that served as the
backdoor pilot for the 1977 Spider-Man
television series Donald only played
Aunt May in the Spider-Man pilot
vermeil's later appearances the role was
assumed by a number of different
actresses including reoccurring Dennis
the Menace star Irene tedrow and of
course many actresses tackled the role
of Aunt May in the world of Animation
before Harris immortalized her on the
big screen June Foray voiced May and
Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends in
which Spidey and Company operated out of
May's Queen's based Abode but you
probably know foray better as the
original voices of both Rocky the flying
squirrel and his arch nemesis Natasha
tall in terms of early Spider-Man
stories you won't find much that's more
iconic Than The Amazing Spider-Man
number 33. this comic titled the Final
Chapter isn't actually co-creator Steve
ditko's final pass at Spider-Man but it
does feel like an end of an era and it
puts Aunt May front and center of the
story as the issue opens ant May lies at
a hospital bed dying from a transfusion
of Peter Parker's radioactive blood the
only cure is an isotope known as ISO 36
which is contained in an underwater lab
controlled by Spider-Man's arch nemesis
Dr Octopus the two fight and destroy the
lab and as it fills with water
Spider-Man is pinned underneath multiple
tons of Fallen steel with no hope of
escape the following four pages are
arguably ditko's finest work in any
Spider-Man comic at least that's what
Stan Lee thinks Lee later said it was
one of my all-time favorite stories it
was such a thrill even to me and I was
the writer of the story when I saw that
I almost shouted in Triumph Steve did a
wonderful job and who does Peter have to
thank for his big moments well did go of
course but also Aunt May as the water
rises Spider-Man thinks about his
beloved aunt and how he's failed her in
the past namely by letting an anonymous
robber get away leaving him free to kill
her husband Ben using May's strength and
resilience's motivation Peter lifts the
steel beams above his head and escapes
he delivers the isotope to the hospital
in the nick of time and with May cured
puts the Specter of Uncle Ben's death
behind him once and for all the scene is
so iconic that it plays out on the big
screen too and Spider-Man homecoming
The Amazing Spider-Man number 121 in
which the Green Goblin kills Peter
Parker's girlfriend Gwen Stacy is
arguably one of the most important and
notorious superhero comics ever
published but it almost played out very
very differently originally Gwen Stacy
was going to make it to the end of the
issue alive and well while Aunt May was
to meet her demise of the Goblin's hands
instead that Revelation comes from none
other than long time Spider-Man artist
John romita Senior who co-plotted the
issue with writer Jerry Conway while
talking to CBR romita confessed that he
and not Conway are artist Gil Kane was
Gwen Stacy's real murderer the original
plan was to sacrifice Aunt May to the
Green Goblin but romita pushed back on
the idea claiming that it would actually
make The Amazing Spider-Man less
dramatic Romina explained it'll lose one
of Peter Parker's Hang-Ups he won't have
to worry about Aunt May anymore he won't
be treated like a child anymore if we
want to make any kind of stir in the
monthly line we have to kill somebody
important and so Romiti explained the
victim had to be one of the stories
leading female figures from there Gwen
Stacy became the obvious choice at the
time Mary Jane was what romita called an
airhead comedy character but Gwen Stacy
was the love of Peter Parker's life in
order to ring the maximum amount of
emotional turmoil out of the story Gwen
had to go and the rest of course is
history
Aunt May's abilities aren't limited to
Simply fretting about the well-being of
superheroes though in fact she's also a
superhero herself sort of and what if
number 23 a backup feature called what
if Aunt May instead of her nephew Peter
had been bitten by that radioactive
spider tells the story about it's kind
of obvious isn't it an Amazing Fantasy
number 15. Peter attends a scientific
demonstration where he crosses paths
with the Fateful radioactive spider in
what if number 23 he leaves his bagged
lunch at home and Aunt May rushes to the
Science Institute to deliver it while
she's there the spider bites May on the
hand and her spider powers kick in on
the walk home May quickly sews herself a
costume and creates a unique version of
Spider-Man's web fluid out of some over
yeasted dough before long she's taken to
the streets as Spider-Man juggling her
crime-fighting career with her familial
responsibilities and while what if
stories aren't canonical writer Christos
Gage and artist Dave Williams made
Spider-Man a reality and Spider-Man team
up number three part of Dan Slaughter
Olivier koi Pell's Dimension hopping
epic spider-verse in the comic a team of
Spider-Man including the Peter Parker we
know and love travel to earth 3123 to
rescue Spider-Man from Karn an
interdimensional Hunter with a mad
hatred for everything spider related the
team is successful but the battle leads
to a dramatic development in
Spider-Man's story she finally reveals
her secret identity to her husband and
nephew whose lives are changed forever
the list of people who have stopped
Galactus Marvel Comics gargantuan
Devourer of Worlds is pretty short the
Fantastic Four have done it of course so
if Thanos the Silver Surfer and the
beyonder and Aunt May wait what this
tale took place in Marvel team up number
137 which was part of Marvel's assistant
editor's month an event during which
some of Marvel's top creators were given
free reign to tell the wildest and
silliest stories they could imagine in
the comic Spider-Man and the Fantastic
Four head off to San Diego to thwart an
unnamed disaster leaving Reed Richards
and Sue Storm's super-powered son
Franklin in Aunt May's care
unfortunately just after the real heroes
leave town Galactus arrives in search of
a new Herald and he's got his sights set
on Franklin one ill-aimed energy blast
later and Aunt May is transformed into
the golden oldie a glowing super heroine
infused with the power of cosmic I
believe there's a hero in all of us
it keeps us honest
gives us strength thanks to Galactus all
of Aunt May's health problems her
arthritis her vitamin deficiencies her
Bingo addiction are gone but there's a
catch Galactus is hungry and it's up to
his Herald to keep him fed at Franklin's
prompting May feeds Galactus a Twinkie
he loves it and demands more using her
Newfound Powers May scours first Earth
then the entire galaxy for more of the
spongy cream-filled snack cakes on her
travels she meets an alien that looks
suspiciously like the Pillsbury Doughboy
who just happens to make planets that
resemble Hostess products at May's
suggestion Galactus takes the alien on
as his new Herald and freeze May from
her responsibilities when she returns
home Franklin absorbs all of May's
Cosmic powers and everything goes back
to normal right before writer Michael
Carlin reveals that the whole Adventure
was just a bad dream or was it Peter
Parker will always be the main man in
May Parker's life but with such a busy
day-to-day life May's nephew doesn't
always have time for his beleaguered
Aunt thankfully despite her age May is
incredibly popular with the fellas and
has accumulated quite a collection of
dudes to keep her company while Peter's
away there was Ben Parker of course who
met his tragic demise in Amazing Fantasy
number 15 but before Ben and may got
hitched she almost married a criminal
named Johnny Jerome who tried to win her
heart with money and who returned to
plague her in the spectacular Spider-Man
Annual number four in The Amazing
Spider-Man number 54 Dr Octopus rents
May's spare room and wins her over with
his charms and in The Amazing Spider-Man
number 131 he actually tries to marry
her in order to steal her inheritance
although Hammerhead and Spider-Man
interrupt the wedding before it becomes
official
real homie oh great it's live throughout
the 80s May dated Nathan lubensky a
reformed gambling addict who asked me to
marry him before he relapsed fell afoul
of the vulture and died an Amazing
Spider-Man number 336 in the early 90s
she enjoyed a brief fling with a
fantastic Four's longtime mailman Willie
Lumpkin after Peter Parker and Aunt May
move to Stark Tower in the build-up to
Civil War May and Tony Stark's Butler
Jarvis shared a mutual attraction
finally Mae dated and married Jay Jonah
Jameson's Father John Jameson senior and
stayed with him until he died of a rare
hereditary disease in The Amazing
Spider-Man Vol 4 number 19.
Aunt May actress Rosemary Harris was 75
in 2002 and Sam raimi's Spider-Man hit
theaters when she appeared as May and
The Amazing Spider-Man Sally Field was
66. by contrast Marissa Tomei who plays
May in the modern MCU was only 50 when
she first starred as Peter Parker's
favorite aunt that's significantly
younger than May is usually portrayed in
Civil War Tony Stark even jokes about it
who else knows anybody
nobody
not even your unusually attractive aunt
but don't blame tomay while appearing on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert Tomei
revealed that she actually petitioned
Marvel to make May into a senior citizen
just like in the comics but the studio
declined I actually made a case to go
with to age me up but no no no besides
as civil war co-writer Stephen mcfeely
has explained a younger Aunt May makes
perfect sense given that Tom Holland's
Peter Parker is still in high school
mcfeely told the Los Angeles Times
that's partly why his aunt isn't 80
years old if she's the sister of his
dead mother why does she have to be two
generations ahead in other words the
mcu's Aunt May isn't too young at all in
the comics she's actually way too old
[Music]
he's Brave he's relatable he's funny
he's friendly spectacular and amazing
but Spider-Man can also be
unprofessional and maybe a little pervy
if you want to keep your childhood
memories of Spidey intact bail out now
but if you want to see Spider-Man for
who he really is warts and all be warned
without the veneer of nostalgia you
might not like what you see fake news
Peter Parker through his work with the
Daily Bugle is a Pulitzer Prize winning
photojournalist and that means he is
expected to adhere to certain ethical
standards he doesn't in fact his entire
career is pretty much a lie while Peter
tells Jay Jonah Jameson that his photos
of Spider-Man swinging through the city
are candid he often stages shots in
order to get the best angle in reality
he's shooting selfies and selling them
as news he creates newsworthy events and
then uses them to his financial
advantage which is borderline evil
Peter's transgressions are serious
enough that he could be legally liable
for misrepresentation for fraud and
breach of contract and he wouldn't have
much of a defense to fall back on in
other words Peter Parker is a hack who
shouldn't be allowed anywhere near a
camera and should never be trusted with
the news and speaking of cameras Mary
Jane's indiscretions it's not just fake
news that Peter's cameras get used for
he also spends a lot of time focusing on
his wife mostly when she's naked which
you may not completely realize as a kid
in Spectacular Spider-Man number 134
Mary Jane takes some sexy shots to
convince Peter to become a fashion
photographer while Peter crawls on the
wall and pulls her to the ceiling for
some adult recreation in The Amazing
Spider-Man number 300 Peter and MJ break
into their new apartment and relieve
some Venom induced stress by taking some
snaps for their private collection in
The Sensational Spider-Man number 20
Peter takes his mind off a string of
recent failures by putting his
photographic talents to use in the
bedroom we just can't figure out why
Mary Jane would be so eager to jump back
in front of the camera during bring her
time off from being a model get a hobby
lady
spider nonsense Peter Parker was given
spider-like Powers by a radioactive
spider bite and for the most part it
checks out clinging to walls sure super
strength absolutely jumping extra high
according to science Spider-Man doesn't
even jump high enough so where the heck
did his famous fighter sense Powers come
from spiders can sense movement in the
air around them using small hairs on
their bodies and they can track the
vibrations in their webs to tell
different types of insects apart that
means that Spider-Man should be able to
identify nearby physical threats but his
Spider Sense does much much more than
that
[Music]
[Applause]
my spider senses are starting to tingle
it tells Peter when an enemy is in
Disguise or if someone is lying it
guides him to Hidden threats it picks up
specific radio frequencies which is how
spider tracers work Spider Sense is less
of a biological function and more of a
psychic power and it's not anything like
a real spider's abilities not even close
with great power
great power comes great responsibility
except that's not actually how it goes
in Amazing Fantasy number 15 the actual
quote reads with great power there must
also come great responsibility that
doesn't flow off the tongue quite as
well as the abbreviated version so it
makes sense that future writers would
try to condense it a little bit it's
also a quote commonly attributed to
Uncle Ben but Ben never actually says
those words in Amazing Fantasy number
15. spidey's first appearance during
Spider-Man's origin story Uncle Ben only
has two lines he wakes up Peter for
school and comments on how Peter is
getting too big to out wrestle thanks to
Aunt May's fat-filled wheat cakes the
quote by which Spider-Man lives his life
is only spoken by an unnamed narrator
who utters the line as Spider-Man
tearfully wanders off into the night
still mourning his uncle's death your
whole life is alive Spider-Man
jokes on Carnage Carnage might be the
coolest Spider-Man villain ever he's
like Venom but faster stronger and looks
like he's made of meat he's more than a
match for most Marvel heroes he has
complete control over his symbiotes and
eats other symbiotes in order to boost
his strength what more could you want in
a bad guy well how about some
originality for starters he's basically
a super-sized version of Venom who's
already basically just Spider-Man but
evil the rip-off report is only getting
started though in his civilian identity
of Cletus Cassidy he closely resembles
yet another famous character if the
maniacal grin sharp cheekbones and The
Psychotic disregard for human life
remind you of a clown-themed villain
you're not alone in 2007 Carnage
co-creator Eric Larson flat out admitted
that Cletus Cassidy is a straight up
Joker knockoff saying he was inspired by
The Joker I basically Drew The Joker and
had him colored with regular skin and
red hair Larson isn't the only only one
who thought Joker and Carnage shared
some strong similarities either in 1995
the Spider-Man and Batman crossover
comic saw the clown Prince of Crime team
up with the Symbiotes to wreak havoc in
Gotham City bringing the Sinister twins
together at last Spider-Man's terrible
friends many Heroes have personal ties
to their arch nemesis but Spider-Man
takes things to a whole new level
basically anyone in Peter Parker's life
who isn't dead turns into a super
villain sooner or later no seriously
there's Norman Osborne of course who
happens to be both his best friend's dad
and the evil Green Goblin once Norman's
out of the picture his son Harry picks
up the pumpkin bombs and Carries on with
the family Legacy the Clone obsessed
Jackal is Peter's college professor
Miles Warren the molten man is The
Stepbrother of Peter's High School Crush
Liz Allen man wolf is Peter's boss's son
while Jay Jonah Jameson himself funded
the creation of the spiders Slayers as
well as the villainous scorpion Ned
Leeds one of Peter's co-workers at The
Daily Bugle spent some time as the
Hobgoblin just for fun and those are
just the classics more recently a good
friend of Aunt May's the philanthropist
Martin Lee turned out to be the evil Mr
negative Harry Osborne's fiancee Lily
Hollister reveals herself as the goblin
themed villain Menace and Phil Urich
nephew of Peter's Daily Bugle pal Ben
yurich decided to terrorize the city as
yet another hobgoblin they say you can't
choose your family but you can choose
your friends if that's really true Peter
choose better these people suck
thank you